battu pour la 2e place
on a parlé des énergies fossiles à ça le
but du jeu d'aujourd'hui
si vous avez quelque chose du coup
dernier c'est cette planche donc très
rapidement en 15 secondes
le monde dans lequel nous vivons 7
millions d'euros 7 ou 8 milliards de
mots industrialis c'est aux énergies
fossiles pour l'essentiel qu'on le doit
qui ont permis d'alimenter un parc de
machines croissant qui a permis de créer
une production croissante qui nous a
donné ce qu'on a coutume d'appeler notre
niveau de vie
vous savez que dans le paysage
médiatique français
il arrive que les titres de journaux ne
reflète pas cette réalité et je pense
qu'il n'y a pas une personne dans cette
salle
malgré votre jeune âge par rapport à moi
en tout cas qui n'est pas entendu que la
france et l onu plus exactement que la
france était un pays tout nucléaire
est-ce que personne est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un dans cette salle qui n'a
jamais entendu ça dans la presse
oui un des meilleurs sur le journal 2
quand vous regardez les débats sur
l'énergie dans la presse française vous
avez un élément absorbant du débat le
nucléaire assez vite se focalise
là-dessus vous avez aussi un graphique
qui a été fait par l'excellent de
société dans laquelle je travaille et
dans laquelle on a regardé de quelle
énergie primaire donc de quelle énergie
tirée de l'environnement se
nourrissaient les machines qui nous
rendent la vie si douce dans le pays
alors selon l'endroit où sont les
machines la colère ne porte pas le même
nom
donc là quand même qui est tout à gauche
industrie c'est des machines
il se trouve dans les industries donc
c'est celle qui servent à fabriquer les
objets qu'on consomme une partie
seulement dans la case transpiration des
machines qui servent à déplacer
des personnes ou des marchandises les
casses tertiaire et résidentiel c'est
des machines qui sont dans des bâtiments
donc typiquement la consommation
d'énergie des radiateurs de l'école des
mines du vidéoprojecteur de l'école des
mines et de la cuisine de l'école des
mines tout ça ça se trouve dans force
hier et enfin si la machine se trouve
dans un champ c'est dans l'agriculture
l'on venait étant milliards de
kilowattheures opéra water et il s'agit
d'énergie finale
il s'agit donc d'énergie qui passe un
compteur avant d'alimenter une machine
c'est de l'énergie qui est payé en
général par le consommateur final pas
toujours mais qui a payé par
consommateur final est ce que je fais
maintenant c'est que je cercle la
totalité de ceux qui en france vient de
combustibles fossiles dans ce qui
alimente parc de machines qui
structurent l'activité du pays ce que
vous pourriez assez facilement voir sur
ce graphique même sans qu'on parle de
chiffres de manière très précise c'est
que l'essentiel de l'énergie dite finale
encore une fois c'est qu'ils passent un
compteur du consommateur final que ce
soit un consommateur particulier ou un
consommateur entreprises et est
constitué d'un vecteur qui a été
fabriqué à partir d'énergies fossiles
alors ce vecteur peut être des câbles en
liquide ça peut être de l'électricité
fait avec du gaz de la chaleur fait avec
du gaz etc
en france est essentiellement des
carburants liquides et du gaz final on
utilise directement pour le chauffage ou
pour d'autres usages dans l'industrie
qui sont l'essentiel de nos combustibles
fossiles on utilise un peu de charbon
pas beaucoup ça fait 10 % notre co2 mais
c'est pas beau c'est encore moins que ça
en quantité d'énergie et l'électricité
qui vient du nucléaire gelé mise à
dessein évidemment puisque je suis un
peu taquin envers envers thierry si oui
par exemple dans le résidentiel
donc là où les gens habitent le blog
l'électricité d'origine nucléaire
représente des approvisionnements
énergétiques qui sont du même ordre de
grandeur
d'autres l'essentiel en france comme
ailleurs de l'énergie qui alimente
l'exosquelette que nous avons créé c'est
des énergies fossiles
alors quand on raisonnera en co2 on
verra qu'on peut pas raisonner
exactement comme ça parce que la
génération électrique se fait avec des
machines de carnot dont vous avez
beaucoup de pertes dans le système mais
sur l'énergie finale c'est très très
facile et bon ces énergies fossiles vous
voyez que ce qui domine
en france comme dans tous les pays de la
zone qu'on appelle ocde c'est à dire les
pays qui sont anciennement
industrialisés pour dire les choses de
manière un peu simple c'est du pétrole
donc l'énergie qui domine dans
l'approvisionnement énergétique des pays
de l' ocde amérique
enfin les états unis canada mexique
l'essentiel de l'europe corée du sud
australie japon etc
c'est du pétrole donc on va commencer
par parler du pétrole le pétrole
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait bien évidemment
une fois qu'on l'a fait sortir de terre
et je reviendrai plus tard on s'en sert
qu'à tel que à peu près aucune machine
sauf les chars d'assaut ne sait utiliser
du pétrole brut
donc on va le raffiner le raffiner ça
veut dire que on le fait passer dans un
grand élan beach un peu moins
intéressant que celui qui vous donnent
de l'autre vit et on va distiller ce
pétrole et en faire donc des fractions
qui sont constitués de molécules qui ne
sont pas de même longueur en ce qui
concerne la chaîne carbonée
donc on va séparer les chaînes carbonées
entre les chaînes courtes et des chaises
longues donc ici vous avez la
décomposition d'un baril de pétrole à
l'arrivée j'ai envie de dire en certiid
raffinerie dans lequel vous avez des
produits qui sont légers dans les
produits légers vous avez le naphta avec
gpl le naphta c'est la base de la
pétrochimie la pétrochimie c'est la
chimie organique donc toute la chimie
organique qu'on a sur terre et abbas gaz
ou pétrole
vous avez de l'essence vous avez du
diesel vous avez dû ciolos qui sont
exactement le même produit vous avez du
kérosène vous allez les bitumes avec
lesquels on recouvre les routes vous
avez des cires et des huiles voilà vous
avez du coke de pétrole
le coke de pétrole c'est le résidu
solide qu'on a enfin de distillation qui
soit dit en passant sert à alimenter
l'énergie de la colonne de distillation
s'est recyclé sur place sauf quelques
usages industriels divers et variés quel
est ce qu'on fait essentiellement d'un
baril de pétrole
si on regarde comment évolue la
consommation du monde en produits
distillés
voilà à quoi ça ressemble donc tout en
haut
vous avez les sens et l'essence aviation
l'essentiel de ce truc là c'est de
l'essence en dessous vous avez du gasoil
et du sud de chauffage et l'essentiel
c'est du gasoil en dessous
vous avez dû cieux qu'on appelait
autrefois du fioul lourd qui sert la
marine marchande dans l'industrie et
dans la génération électrique et là vous
allez tout le reste donc le naphta les
cires les huiles le bitume le coke de
pétrole etc
dans le monde la consommation de chacun
de ces produits augmentent
maintenant si je regarde l'europe
pourrait que c'est un peu différent je
vous ai dit la dernière fois que
l'europe était déjà depuis 2005 sous
stress l'approvisionnement ce qui
concerne son pétrole
elle n'arrive plus à suivre la tendance
mondiale pour des raisons sur lesquelles
j'ai un peu évoquée on est amer à
aujourd'hui et vous voyez que
l'essentiel de ce que concerne l'europe
en ce qui concerne les produits raffinés
c'est du diesel et du soul que vous avez
là c'est pas propre en france 1 il ya eu
un mouvement croissant de consommation
de diesel de fioul pardon et de kérosène
le kérosène pour l'aviation est
également là dedans si vous regardez
pour le monde va son ensemble en ce qui
concerne les produits raffinés vous
voyez que c'est je vais pas rentrer dans
les détails mais ce qui est important de
noter c'est que c'est le les transports
routiers qui car oui vous avez à la fois
elle a sorti du fioul dans la génération
électrique
il ya deux mois on il ya eu de moins en
moins de fuel est sorti du fuel de
l'industrie par l'oms a été remplacé par
du gaz c'est sûr les deux les deux
basculement principaux et par ailleurs
on a progressivement adapter les
raffineries parce que en bronze dans une
raffinerie vous rentrez un paquet
données d'atomes de carbone et d'atomes
d'hydrogène est tout ce que vous allez
faire dans leur raffinerie c'est que
vous les réarranger de façon différente
mais grâce à ce cher lavoisier tout le
carbone que vous ne retrouvez pas dans
des produits légers du coup vous allez
retrouver dans des produits lourds
donc si vous organisez ce qu'on appelle
votre coupe de raffineries c'est à dire
la manière dont se décompose des
produits en sortant de raffinerie en
donnant de l'avantagé à des produits
plus légers que le fuel lourd parce que
vous voulez augmenter la part d'essence
et de diesel
à ce moment vous allez aussi
corrélativement augmenter la part de
bitume de cire et d'huile dont vous
savez pas nécessairement que faire donc
vous avez toujours un arbitrage qui ce
qui se passe est l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles en france on a fiscalement
avantages et le diesel
c'est que au moment il ya eu un moment
en france où l'on consommé entre
guillemets trop d'essence par rapport à
ce que savait sortir les raffineries et
donc à ce moment on a cherché à
favoriser le diesel histoire de
rééquilibrer la donne notamment après
les chocs pétroliers quand le fuel est
sorti rapidement du chauffage des
habitations d'accord pour qu'on s'est
dit là on se retrouve avec plein de fuel
sur les bras on sait pas quoi en faire
et donc on va essayer de le faire
consommer par des voitures n'étaient pas
du tout un complot des constructeurs
parce que ils voulaient qu'il ya des
particules fines partout c'était juste
un rééquilibrage des produits de sortie
des raffineries dès demain matin si on
dit qu'on interdit diesel soit dit en
passant on se retrouve avec 30% de la
coupe de raffineries sur les bras
d'antan sait pas quoi faire admettre
dans le chauffage puisqu'on veut sortir
le fioul de chauffage pour des raisons
de climat
mettez pas dans l'industrie pour la même
raison m'étais pas donc je dis pas que
il faut rester comme je dis juste ces
voix là c'est un truc à prendre en
compte apprendre à garder en tête et une
raffinerie c'est pas quelque chose qui
se paramètre d'un jour sur l'autre sur
une fois que vous avez construit votre
raffinerie pour qu'elle ait une
décomposition données en bitume à te
faire en fait ces décès des prises dans
une colonne de distillation que sur des
prises physique à des hauteurs donné
dans la colonne de distillation donc
vous débranchez pas le machin pour leur
mettre dix mètres plus bas en dix ans je
vais changer le fractionnement mama
raffinerie quoi c'est des travaux durs
qui sont nécessaires pour faire ce genre
de choses
donc je disais l'essentiel de produits
raffinés servent transports aujourd'hui
dans le monde et en particulier aux
transports routiers j'ai dit la dernière
fois mais je le répète 98% du transport
planétaire est fait avec du pétrole
l'électricité est marginal le gaz est
marginal c'est vraiment le pétrole qui
domine de la tête et des épaules dans
les échoppes vendant dans les transports
ce qui veut dire aussi une chose c'est
que le pétrole est par essence pardon du
mauvais jeu de mots l'énergie de la
mondialisation
alors y'a pas de mondialisation sans
pétrole est symétriquement ok de la
mondialisation il faut du pétrole
voilà maintenant une décomposition de la
consommation de pétrole par zen lorsque
vous voyez c'est que la consommation des
etats unis elle est raisonnablement
constante depuis longtemps et que c'est
depuis longtemps dans cette
décomposition là le premier consommateur
de pétrole dans le monde
aujourd'hui encore les états unis
consomment pas loin d'un cinquième du
pétrole mondial
ce qui fait quand même beaucoup pour un
pays qui fait pas un cinquième de la
population mondiale mais plutôt 5%
et puis ensuite vous avez diverses
diverses zones
vous noterez évidemment l'essor de la
chine dans l'est dans les périodes
récentes à côté du pétrole
on conserve aussi du gaz vous avez ici
la décomposition de la destination du
gaz utilisé dans le monde
là il s'agit bien dans le monde dont
l'entretenez congrue vous avez trop gros
pack et électricité industrie chauffage
pour le dire de manière très simple en
france c'est le chauffage qui domine de
très loin on a à peu près 60% du gascon
consonnes qui est utilisé dans le
chauffage mais ombreux dans le monde
encore une fois c'est électricité
industrie chauffage
enfin un concept du charbon dans le
monde et ici vous avez une décomposition
de la consommation de charbon par pays
depuis 1965
alors vous voyez il ya grosse bosse
c'est l'essor industriel de la chine
mais avant elle je vous signale que
l'essor industriel de la corée s'est
fait exactement de la même manière
la korea multi corée du sud a multiplié
ses émissions de co2 par 27 entendu bien
par 27 entre 1965 et aujourd'hui donc là
vous avez exactement le même processus
qui s'est produit pour la chine qui
était insignifiante dans la consommation
de charbon en 1965 et qui aujourd'hui on
utilise la moitié dans le monde alors le
charbon à quoi ça sert je l'avais dit la
dernière fois j'ai essayé de trouver des
chiffres plus récents mais j'y suis pas
arrivé mais enfin bon je sais que c'est
toujours 0 paquet l'essentiel du charbon
qu'on utilise dans le monde sert à la
production électrique en gros les deux
tiers et dans le tiers restant vous avez
une matière en gros qui sert à la
production d'acier du charbon
métallurgique
alors ces énergies ne sont pas égales en
ce qui concerne le rayonnement
géographique
je vais pas prévu de planches pour ça
mais le la seule énergie mondiale que
nous ayons et pour des raisons physiques
c'est le pétrole donc le pétrole est la
seule énergie pour laquelle vous avez
plus des deux tiers de la production
mondiale qui passe une frontière entre
le pays de production et le pays de
consommation et la raison à cela c'est
que le pétrole est très dense par unité
de volume c'est la plus dense des
énergies fossiles par unité de volume
vous avez dit kilowattheure
les autres énergies font pas ça dans un
livre de gaza température et pression
ambiante vous avez mille fois moins
d'énergie en eau et dans un litre de
charbon vous avez 3 à 4 fois moins
d'énergie donc enfin deux fois ça dépend
la qualité du charbon est par ailleurs
ces liquides donc ça se transvase donc
ça se transporte et ça ce stock
extrêmement facilement avec des
déperditions d'énergie dans la chaîne de
logistique qui sont très très faible en
ce qui concerne le gaz
vous n'avez que 30% du gaz produit dans
le monde qui passe une frontière entre
pays de production et pays de
consommation et là dedans vous n'avez
que 10% qui trace donc 10 sur 30 10 % de
la production mondiale de gaz qui
transite sous forme de gaz liquéfié de
gaz naturel liquéfié
or le gaz naturel liquéfié qui se
transporte dans des méthaniers qui
volent espèce de grand frigo sur l'eau
ces endroits où ces comprimés et surtout
froid donc le gaz pour que le bétail
folie qu'ils sont c'est la seule forme
de transport qui est arbitrable à la
demande comme le pétrole sur le pétrole
vous avez mon négociant suisse de
vitrolles qui est là-dessous bla qui dit
alors le bateau qui à tel endroit où
vous achète votre cargaison combien
envers cependant moi je vous l'achète un
centime de plus le bar in si vous allez
à rotterdam ou si vous allez à la
nouvelle orléans dont crack vous allez
changer d'autres donc vous pouvez faire
ça avec le pétrole ça se fait du reste
le pétrole papier le multiple des
échanges par rapport au pétrole physique
je crois que c'est un facteur 100 donc
ça va c'est une autre manière de dire
qu'une cargaison allaient négocier des
dizaines de fois entre son point de
départ et son point d'arrivée alors que
lens qui concerne le gaz pour le gaz par
'pipeline' vous pouvez pas faire ça il
fait que vous avez mis le 'pipeline'
entre la russie et l'allemagne
vous n'avez qu'un seul producteur la
russie ait qu'un seul client l'allemagne
et vous pouvez pas avoir à négocier en
doute son téléphone qui dit ah bah tiens
ça c'est quand même vachement mieux de
mettre le tuyau en iran et de mettre
l'arrivée du tuyau en espagne peut pas
faire un truc comme ça
donc les échanges internationaux de gaz
par gazoduc sont des échanges qui sont
très rigides
puisque vous avez un producteur et un
consommateur de l'autre côté et soit dit
en passant c'est la raison pour laquelle
historiquement le prix du gaz a été
calée sur le prix du pétrole
parce que le gars
et paie un substitut au pétrole et il
fallait être absolument sûr tant du côté
producteurs que du côté consommateur qui
en aurait pas envie d'arrêter de
consommer du gaz en fonction de ce qui
était le prix du pétrole donc on s'est
dit le meilleur moyen c'est que les deux
veulent la même chose comme ça on est
tranquille et c'est la façon dont les
contrats de gaz se sont mis en place
dans le monde c'est pour ça que le gaz à
peu près partout maintenant sauf
quelques exceptions indexé sur le sur le
prix du pétrole le charbon or charbon
métallurgique qui est un charbon qui
vaut cher parce qu'il sert à faire de
l'acier et que vous avez que quelques
mines qui s'affairent du charbon
métallurgique dans le monde c'est-à-dire
du charbon à très haute teneur en
carbone qui va servir à donner ensuite
du coq au masculin et bien à part le
charbon métallurgique vous n'avez que
10% du charbon extrait d'une mine dans
le monde qui passe une frontière entre
le pays de production il paye
consommation donc retenu que quand on va
du pétrole vers le charbon en passant
par le gaz on va d'une énergie qui est
mondial par essence à une énergie qui
est domestique par essence et c'est la
raison aussi pour laquelle dans les pays
qui ne consomment pas de charbon en
direct ce qui est le cas de la france on
a tendance à oublier sa place chez les
autres parce que encore une fois ce qui
se passe dans un pays donné et
raisonnablement indépendant de ce qui se
passe dans les autres pays
en ce qui concerne le charbon ce que
vous voyez ici par exemple c'est que
alors que la chine explose en ce qui
concerne la consommation de charbon
vous avez d'autres zones dans le monde
qui augmente aussi mais vous en avez qui
diminuée si je prend l'ensemble du reste
du monde vous voyez il n'y a pas une
grosse grosse différence entre la et l'a
donc la consommation de charbon est une
affaire domestique
je le redis la consommation de gaz une
affaire régionale qui schématise et la
consommation de pétrole une affaire
mondiale
alors en france nous consommons des
énergies fossiles voilà déjà la
consommation de pétrole dans le pays
lorsque vous voyez c'est que la
consommation de pétrole a augmenté très
fortement jusqu'à ces fameux choc
pétrolier dont je vous ai parlé la
dernière fois et dont je rappelle qu'ils
sont la marque de l'arrêt de la
croissance de la quantité de pétrole
consommés par les pays de l' ocde
c'est ça les chocs pétroliers donc c'est
pas juste une variation du prix c'est
une variation instantanée sur le volume
et qui a été extrêmement structurantes
sur ce qui s'est passé ensuite dans
l'économie ce que vous voyez c'est qu'au
moment des chocs pétroliers
vous avez une bonne partie du pétrole
qui est consommé par l'industrie ça
répond à la question qui était fait tout
à l'heure une partie par les transports
une bonne partie dans le chauffage
résidentiel et tertiaire et vous avez
toujours eu une petite partie de
l'agriculture importante pour la
productivité des agriculteurs mais
marginal pour la consommation d'ensemble
alors ne faites pas attention à ce qui
se passe là sur le switch entre
résidentiel et tertiaire parce que mon
hypothèse c'est que c'est un soin une
erreur soit un artefact statistique
s'était recueilli à une catégorie de
bâtiments qui a dû être passé de
d'une catégorie à l'autre regardez le
volume global de ce qui est consommé
dans les bâtiments et vous voyez que
c'était beaucoup plus important au
moment des chocs pétroliers que
aujourd'hui où ça a été déplacé par du
gaz et de l'électricité
ce que vous voyez c'est qu'aujourd'hui
l'essentiel du pétrole qu'on consomme en
france va dans les transports
et soit dit en passant c'est aussi là
que le consommateur final est prêt à le
payer le plus cher donc c'est pas
complètement
étonnant j'ai envie de dire en termes
d'arbitrages si vous êtes vendeur de
produits raffinés c'est bien ça que vous
allez chercher à faire c'est à le vendre
là où le consommateur est prêt à le
payer plus cher oui vous n'avez pas
écouté ce que j'ai dit bon je viens de
derrière 30 secondes ne fait pas
attention à ça c'est probablement un
artefact statistique ou une erreur non
non non voilà donc c'est le je ne sais
pas il faudrait que je regarde
par contre ce que je sais c'est que le
total des deux c'est l'ensemble de ce
qui est consommé dans les bâtiments est
ce assez représentatif de la c1 fichiers
statistiques que j'ai récupéré sur le
site du ministère
et donc il faudra que j'écrive à qui de
droit pour savoir à quoi ça correspond
je suis par contre totalement confiant
dans la tendance globale pour l'ensemble
des bâtiments
parce que ça c'est clair que c'était une
substitution par d'électricité et part
du gaz dans bon nombre de dents bon
nombre des cas de figure en ce qui
concerne pardon le gaz va y arriver oui
pourquoi tu as jamais une animation sur
le titre voilà une balle au gaz utilisé
en france
donc ce que vous voyez c'est que le
premier poste de consommation du gaz
utilisé en france c'est le chauffage
vous en avez un petit morceau qui va
dans l'électricité mais en gros c'est la
moitié de la petite partie qui est en
haut
et puis tout en bas vous en avez
également une partie qui va dans
l'industrie alors noté un truc
intéressant
je vous en avais déjà parlé la dernière
fois rapidement mais je le redis depuis
que la mer du nord a passé son pic
c'est de son pic de production
c'est-à-dire 2005
vous voyez que la consommation de gaz en
france s'est arrêtée de croître et
qu'elle est globalement
et croissance pour l'ensemble bâtiment
et industrie où la mer du nord passe son
pic le gaz de la mer du nord c'est 60 %
de l'approvisionnement européen
aujourd'hui c'est encore 50% et on va
voir dans pas longtemps que lorsque la
norvège va passer son pic
parce que c'était encore le cas
probablement que l'approvisionnement de
la mer du nord va descendre encore d'une
grosse marche d'escalier
enfin nous utilisons du charbon en
france donc ici vous avez de la quantité
de charbon utilisé par secteur vous
voyez à nouveau que alors le haut
fourneau et cokerie c'est l'ensemble de
ce qui est utilisé dans la sidérurgie
les cokeries comme je le disais tout à
l'heure fond du charbon fond du coq à
partir du charbon sert du carbone
presque pur et donc pour ça on a un
traitement spécial du charbon qui on
utilise également du charbon qu'on en
font le directement tel que dans les
dents les dans les industries au dessus
vous avez sauf erreur de ma part ou à
l'électricité et les réseaux de chaleur
mais surtout l'électricité vous voyez
que ça va beaucoup diminuer et puis
ensuite il vous reste quelques petites
bricoles mais enfin c'est pas grand
chose le charbon en france comme je le
disais tout à l'heure
puisque la consommation primaire totale
de la france c'est 240 millions de
tonnes équivalent pétrole
là vous voyez aujourd'hui le charbon est
à moins de 10 donc c'est pas grand chose
donc voilà le combustible fossile
rapidement tel qu on les consomme dans
le monde et en france et pour quels
types d' usage
alors maintenant on va essayer de
comprendre d'où ils sentent le
dictionnaire étant bien fait les
combustibles fossiles sont faux cils
fossiles ça veut dire que c'est un reste
de vie ancienne et c'est très exactement
ce que sont les combustibles fossiles
alors la façon dont ils sont apparus
sous nos pieds est la suivante vous avez
depuis très longtemps des océans sur
terre et dans ses océans vous avez
depuis très longtemps des êtres uni ou
pluricellulaires qui sont apparues et
qui vivent dans ces êtres unis ou
pluricellulaires vous avez notamment des
algues et du
en temps alors ces êtres comme nous ne
sont pas plus immortel c'est un peu de
temps en temps hélas pour eux il passe
de vie à trépas
et quand il passe de vie à trépas
l'essentiel d'entre eux sont des
composés dans la colonne d'eau c'est à
dire qu' il reste ne tombe pas sur le
plancher océanique
mais vous avez quand même une petite
partie de ces restes organiques qui
tombe sur le plancher océanique
l'a8 sont en dessous ce qui est souvent
en général le processus que je vais vous
décrire arrive plus tôt près des côtes
là où la hauteur d'eau et pas très
épaisse parce que c'est là que vous avez
les éléments minéraux qui permettent à
la vie d'être la plus abondante et du
coup ça veut dire que c'est là qu'il ya
la plus grande probabilité que les
restes organiques tombe sur le plancher
sens est décomposé dans la colonne d'eau
quand ils tombent sur le plancher
océanique qui vont se retrouver mélangés
à des sédiments minéraux qui sont des
poussières a mené par le vent des
alluvions a mené par les rivières des
coquilles des restes de coquilles pour
les êtres qui en ont une
parce qu'une partie du plancton une
bonne partie du plancton synthétise des
coquilles en calcaire et tout ça va se
mélanger et si vous êtes dans un endroit
approprié
eh bien d'abord ça va se compacter sous
l'effet de son propre poids
ce sédiment et ensuite la tectonique des
plaques va vous entraîner sa vers les
profondeurs et à partir du moment où la
tectonique des plaques vous entraînera
vers les profondeurs elle vous rapproche
du gros radiateur que vous avez au
centre de la terre qui est entretenue
soit dit en passant par la radioactivité
naturelle des roches aujourd'hui et ça
va engendrer une succession de
dégradation ou de décomposition de ce
que vous avez dans le sédiment alors
avec cette ce mouvement de 2,2 j'ai
envie de dire de sédimentation et
d'entraînement vers les profondeurs la
partie minérales du sédiment va se
transformer en ce qu'on appelle une
roche mère cercle de trucs à se
compacter et se transformer en roche et
la partie organique qui est dans des
petites inclusion dans ce sédiment va
elle même subir un certain nombre de
dégradations dans un premier temps vous
avez une dégradation qui est matériel et
vous voyez là et ça va vous expulser de
l'eau et du gaz carbonique dans un
deuxième temps cette dégradation elle va
devenir thermique anaérobie hélas ce
moment vous avez comme dans une
raffinerie un fractionnement de la
matière organique qui est contenu dans
la roche et qui va donner exactement
comme dans une raffinerie
trois types de chaînes organes et en
reining pardon vous allez avoir du gaz
vous allez avoir du liquide qu'on a
coutume d'appeler de l'huile et vous
allez avoir du kérogène c'est à dire du
adua résidus solides pardon qui
ressemble à du charbon et qui va rester
contenue dans la roche
alors primitivement ce truc là s'appelle
du kérogène et une fois qu'il a fini
d'être pyrolyse et à ce moment vous avez
du gaz de l'huile et de la le reste le
reste solide une fois que ces composants
fluide pour le gaz et le pétrole est
solide ont été faits il peut leur
arriver deux choses la première c'est
qu'ils restent là où ils sont parce que
le sédiment à former une roche qui est
imperméable et à ce moment ci la roche
est imperméable et bien la décomposition
de la matière organique reste à whalley
ou bien la roche est perméable et à ce
moment vous allez avoir à l'intérieur de
la roche sous l'effet de la pression
ce qu'on appelle une migration primaire
c'est à dire que le pétrole et le gaz
qui ont été formés vos diffusé à
l'intérieur de la roche et vont
commencer à migrer à l'intérieur de la
roche en ayant envie parce que c'est le
gradient de pression qui les pousse
comme ça de remonter vers la surface
si jamais la pyrolyse et incomplètes
c'est à dire que le phénomène de
tectonique et de dégradations a pris
place
il ya trop peu de temps vous avez un une
roche en grosses roches riches en
matière organique qui s'appelle des
schistes bitumineux
à ne pas confondre avec les sables
bitumineux et en anglais ça s'appelle
une chaise à ne pas confondre avec celle
où elle pour utiliser
ce produit là vous devez finir de le
chauffer à la mano c'est comme ça qu'on
s'en sert et donc vous avez des
centrales électriques j'avais une
centrale électrique qui fonctionne je
sais pas où dans le monde avec un très
très mauvais rendement parce que le
produit a un pouvoir calorifique fel de
très très haut rendement et un très très
mauvais pardon rendement énergétique
on peut se servir de ces schistes
bitumineux en amenant des grandes
quantités d'énergie pour finir
artificiellement la transformation et
donc récupérer du pétrole mais avec un
rendement général qui est inférieur à 1
alors il ya des gens qui imagine par
exemple utiliser de la vapeur nucléaire
pour faire ce genre de truc auquel cas
vous injecter un type d'énergie dans le
sol vous récupérez un autre type
d'énergie en sortie du sol et comme
c'est pas là même qui vous intéressent
on peut imaginer qu économiquement ça
puisse valeur le savent a jamais
énormément se développer si vous avez
les produits qui ont été formés jusqu'à
leur terme dont vous avez effectivement
du gaz ou du pétrole qui est s'est
formée dans la roche mais qui est resté
prisonnier
on verra à la planche suivante que ça
porte un nom extrêmement connue si vous
n'avez pas du plancton mais qu'à la
place vous avez des fougères
c'est ce qui s'est passé sur terre à
l'ère du charbon au carbonifère à ce
moment vous avez des veines de charbon
alors retenez soit dit en passant que
quand vous avez des fougères et non pas
du plancton à qui il arrive ce processus
est bien la veine de charbon quand elles
se forment produit aussi du pétrole et
produit aussi du gaz exactement dans le
même processus de décomposition et de
pyrolyse créé par la chaleur de la terre
alors le pétrole en général s'échappe
par contre une partie du méthane reste
absorbé dans la veine de charbon et
c'est ça qui fait que quand vous avez
une exploitation charbonnières et que
vous remettez la veine de charbon à la
pression atmosphérique
le méthane ceux des sorgues et si
j'avais voulu ventilé pas les mines
eh bien vous avez des coups de grisou
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous avez
du méthane soit absorbée dans le charbon
soit carrément des poches de méthane
dans les veines de charbon
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous en
avez c'est à cause du processus de
formation
vous avez donc la roche qui se retrouve
loin sous terre il a fallu des millions
d'années où des dizaines de millions
d'années pour que tout ça se produise on
verra après donc vous avez la roche qui
est sous terre qui a emprisonné ces
matières organiques qui a produit du
pétrole et du gaz est donc ce pétrole et
ce gaz vont avoir tendance
comme je le disais à migrer de façon
primaire
après une fois qu'il ya eu l'expulsion
des alvéoles là le pétrole et le gaz
vont sortir de la roche-mère et migrer
vers la surface et donc ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle la migration secondaire
alors l'essentiel du temps cette
migration vers la surface et complète
c'est à dire que depuis les 10 20 30 40
50 ou 100 millions d'années que le
pétrole a été formé il migre
doucettement vers la surface arrive en
surface c'est un produit organique qui
se décompose c'est à dire qu'il se fait
bouffer par les bactéries
fin de l'histoire de temps en temps dans
sa migration vers la surface
il est coincé c'est à dire que vous avez
une roche imperméable parce que en
général dans la surface vous n'avez pas
des trous sous la surface n'est pas des
trous donc à un moment vous avez une
roche perméable qui est surmontée par
une roche imperméable et à ce moment
vous avez ce que dans le jargon des
géologues pétroliers on appelle un piège
c'est à dire que le pétrole qui est
formé par la roche mère qui est en
dessous migrent doucettement jusqu'au
moment où ils arrivent dans la roche qui
se deviendra la roche réservoir au
dessus il peut pas aller plus haut parce
que c est une couche imperméable et donc
il va s'accumuler dans la roche
réservoir en général dans la roche
réservoir la porosité était remplie
était remplie d'eau avant et ça explique
pourquoi aujourd'hui dans un réservoir
de pétrole
vous avez toujours sous le pétrole dans
leurs erreurs de pétrole classique
conventionnel vous avez une couche d'eau
sous la couche de pétrole ou plus
exactement sous la partie imprégné de
pétrole vous avez une partie imprégné
d'eau toujours
il se peut que le pétrole a été piégé à
moins de 500 mètres sous terre auquel ce
cas on a l'habitude d'appeler ça du
pétrole conventionnel
s'il est à plus de 500 mètres sous terre
où exactement en plus de 500 mètres sous
l'eau on appelle ça de leur short préfet
quand le pétrole ne crée que sa
migration primaire mais pas secondaire
ou même pas sa migration primaire il
vous reste une roche mère contenant des
hydrocarbures
ce qui a donné lieu récemment aux états
unis à une explosion de la production de
pétrole
c'est le pétrole issu de ces roches
mères dont le pétrole ne s'était pas
échappé et qu en anglais on appelle
duché lauréat par une chaise sur les
schistes bitumineux chez l'oeil dans
l'autre sens donc est ce que en français
ont traduit mal par pétrole de schiste
en l'occurrence on le traduit mal parce
que c'est pas toujours un schiste qui
est la roche-mère mais peu importe les
français aiment bien faire des
traductions approximatives des termes
anglais
donc c'est du pétrole de roche-mère
alors vous avez en fait deux types de
l'exploitation de pétrole de roche-mère
vous avez le pétrole qui est vraiment
dans la roche mère où le pétrole a migré
dans des petites inclusion poreuse qui
sont dans la roche mère et à ce moment
ça s'appelle pas du che l'oeil ça
s'appelle du tight ol alors dans les
deux cas de figure comme le pétrole ne
circule pas dans la roche
c'est la raison pour laquelle il est il
est parlé se promener ailleurs il faut
créer artificiellement la circulation
dans la roche pour pouvoir faire sortir
le pétrole et c'est l'objet de la
fracturation
donc en fait la fracturation conduit à
créer dans la roche-mère un réseau de
fissures qui permet au pétrole qui ne
circulent pas de se mettre à circuler
mais évidemment l'énergie tracts
duration est une énergie significative
ce qui fait que le rendement énergétique
de l'extraction de
du pétrole de roche mère est plus
mauvais que le rendement d'extraction du
pétrole dits conventionnels
donc voilà en gros la façon dont se
présenta formation du pétrole et du gaz
c'est la même chose pour le gaz donc le
gaz qui reste prisonnier dans la roche
mère ou dans d inclusion dans la roche
mère ou dans des réservoirs qui ont
rejeté dimanche et s'appelle shale gas
gas gas de la même manière
alors voilà quelques exemples de
réservoir bon c'est juste pour la petite
histoire ce qui veut dire soit dit en
passant que quand les géologues cherche
du pétrole ils cherchent pas au hasard
ils savent qu'ils doivent chercher dans
des bassins sédimentaires
ils savent que s'il ya du sel qui se
baladent quelque part peut-être que ça
sent bon pour eux etc
il arrive parfois que le la fin de route
du pétrole qui a été formé sous sol soit
du sable qui est situé en surface
donc à ce moment le pétrole va faire
comme si c'était une roche poreuse sous
terre il va s'accumuler dans le sable
mais comme le sable communique avec la
surface à ce moment le pétrole va perdre
ses éléments les plus volatils et vous
vous retrouvez avec ce qu'on appelle des
sables bitumineux
c'est exactement ce que vous avez au
canada dans la province de l'athabasca
et à ce moment ça s'exploite comme des
mines à ciel ouvert donc c'est
aujourd'hui vous avez une photo c'est à
peu près aussi sympathique que les
exploitations de mine à ciel ouvert de
l'inite dont vous faites un grand machin
qui fait 5 km sur 10 km de décaper tout
ce qui est au dessus je peux vous dire
qu'il reste pas un lapin un arbre et
avec des énormes excavatrice vous allez
récupérer ce truc là comme dans une
exploitation de mine à ciel ouvert et
vous emmener sa dans d autres greder
c'est à dire des raffineries d'un genre
particulier qui vous transforme ce
mélange de bitume et de sable en quelque
chose de sympathique qui va entrer dans
votre voiture avec là aussi un rendement
énergétique qui est beaucoup plus
mauvais que celui que vous avez dans une
chaîne pétrolière traditionnel parce que
il faut créer en gros vous avez perdu
les éléments les plus intéressants les
éléments les plus volatils
et donc vous avez un pétrole de moins
bonne qualité
quand vous avez un réservoir
conventionnelle de pétrole et de gaz
l'histoire ne s'arrête pas
nécessairement là comme il a été fermé
dans une région où il ya de la
subduction et bien l'histoire peut
recommencer et donc votre réservoir de
pétrole et de gaz peut lui-même être
entraînés vers les profondeurs et en ce
moment il ya de nouvelles destinations
qui arrive ce qui fait que quand on
cherche du pétrole et du gaz
il ya ce qu'on appelle une fenêtre à
huile c'est à dire une profondeur où on
se dit là si on trouve quelque chose il
va peut-être y avoir du pétrole
et il ya une profondeur en dessous de
laquelle si on trouve quelque chose
c'est nécessairement essentiellement du
gaz parce que c'est un ancien réservoir
de pétrole qui a été ré entraîner vers
les profondeurs où la chaleur a
fractionné le pétrole en molécules plus
courte historiquement soit dit en
passant
quand les pétroliers trouver du gaz il
ya cinquante ans c'était une absolue
calamité pour eux parce que le pétrole
c'est facile à évacuer d'un puits ou
vous soyez vous le mettez dans une cuve
sur route s'appelle un camion et voulant
embarquer en ce qui concerne le gaz vous
mettez pas le gaz dans un camion parce
que le gaz est 1000 fois moins dense que
le pétrole à température et pression
ordinaire donc il faut vraiment avoir un
tuyau pour être capable de les évacuer
et si vous allez faire un trou au milieu
de l'iran et que vous trouvez du gaz ya
pas de tuyaux et donc vous demander ce
que vous en faites
et si vous allez faire un trou au milieu
du golfe de guinée que vous trouvez du
gaz marie ce que vous en faites pas ce
qu'il y'a pas de tuyaux pour évacuer le
gall si la raison pour laquelle dans les
exploitations moderne de gaz offshore
aujourd'hui on fait non seulement le
puits mais la plateforme de liquéfaction
parce que si on avait juste gaz on ne
saurait pas quoi en faire
y'a pas de tuyaux pour l'évacuer c'est
aussi la raison pour laquelle
historiquement les pétroliers laisser
fuir le gaz dans l'atmosphère quand il
trouvait un gisement combiné de pétrole
et gaz toujours pour la même raison
parce qu'ils savaient pas quoi faire du
gaz s'ils étaient loin de toute
infrastructure et donc il le laisser
partir dans l'atmosphère alors depuis
qu'on leur a dit le méthane a un pouvoir
de réchauffement beaucoup plus élevé que
le co2 est a minima et le bruit alors je
reprends
voilà du pétrole à son origine s'est
plaint de carbone voilà l'histoire par
laquelle ça passe et voilà à quoi on
arrive après quelques millions à
centaines de millions d'années
d'évolution et si vous faites le chat
d'oc au bon endroit et bien vous ferez
sortir du pétrole alors je vous l'avais
dit la dernière fois je le répète ce
processus de formation du pétrole est
aussi gratuit que le processus
d'apparition du vent donc je ré insiste
toutes les énergies sont gratuites vous
n'avez pas payé le plancton qui a vécu
dans l'océan il ya 300 millions d'années
et vous n'avez pas payé la géothermie
qui vous a distillé le kérogène et vous
n'avez pas payé la tectonique des
plaques qui vous a enfoui sous terre
rien encore donc le pétrole est gratuit
exactement comme le vent le charbon le
gaz etc
c'est gratuit et c'est vieux vous avez
oui
j'entends bien je vais venir après c'est
parce qu'en fait vous n'avez qu'une
toute petite partie de la matière
organique qui a vécu sur terre qui se
retrouve aujourd'hui sous forme de
résidus pétroliers et gaziers ou
charbonnier
le reste s'est décomposé naturellement
j'ai envie de dire ou bien ses formes et
s'est transformé en pétrole et gaz et ça
à migrer jusqu'à la surface et ça s'est
décomposé après d'accord donc en gros si
vous prenez la totalité du carbone qui a
été à un moment contenue dans les êtres
vivants et que vous rapportez ça à ce
qui est contenu dans les réservoirs
fossiles c'est une toute petite partie
donc c'est un processus d'accumulation
qui porte sur une tout petite exutoire
de la chaîne ici vous avez une
représentation de la fraction des
réserves de pétrole et de gaz en
fonction de leur ancienneté
alors c'est une autre manière de dire
que c'est le temps qu'il faut attendre
pour que se reconstituent les réserves
c'est une autre manière de présenter
exactement la même information
donc ce que vous voyez c'est que une
petite partie du pétrole et on va dire
raisonnablement jeune encore que le
raisonnablement dans cette affaire mais
vous pouvez avoir une fraction
significative du pétrole sur terre qui à
plusieurs centaines de millions d'années
donc le pétrole c'est quelque chose qui
est renouvelable si vous pouvez attendre
quelques centaines ou quelques dizaines
de millions d'années mais si vous êtes
un peu plus impatients c'est pas trés
renouvelables soit dit en passant j'en
profite également pour faire une
remarque qui a son importance dans le
débat qui s'ouvre en france sur la
question du confinement des déchets
nucléaires
quand vous avez un gisement de pétrole
qui date de quelques dizaines de
millions d'années ce qu'on a dit
implicitement c'est que pendant quelques
dizaines de millions d'années vous avez
un produit qui est chaud et liquides qui
restait confiné au même endroit que ça
contient on dit que le réservoir a tenu
pendant quelques dizaines de millions
d'années sur un truc qui est chaud et
liquides voilà donc le confinement
géologique
si vous vous y prenez bien c'est quelque
chose qui tient très très longtemps sans
problème ce n'est pas toujours le cas
mais si on s'y prend bien soutien très
longtemps alors maintenant je vais un
peu vous faire mal à la tête
en vous disant un truc qui n'est
peut-être pas totalement intuitif mais
qui a son importance quand on regarde
les chiffres on savait qu'on peut pas
manipuler des statistiques ces
nomenclatures temps que je vous ai pas
dit ah voilà à quoi sert voilà ce que
c'est qu'une chaussure je peux pas
compter les chaussures et bien en ce qui
concerne le pétrole vous pouvez vous
dire ma le pétrole c'est très simple il
ya du pétrole
il en compte le pétrole mais en fait
c'est pas simple du tout parce que dans
le pétrole vous mettez des produits qui
ne viennent pas du même endroit qui ne
s'appelle pas de la même façon et qui ne
servent pas à la même chose
historiquement ce qu'ils avaient dans le
pétrole c'était ce qui sortait des
gisements de pétrole sans traitement on
va dire donc c'est au moment où monsieur
drac commence à donner des coups de
pioche à titusville il ya des puits
éruptif il sort un machin liquide
il colle ça dans des barils raison soit
dit en passant pour laquelle on compte
le pétrole en barils c'est parce que au
début de l'exploitation du pétrole
les récipients qu'on avait sous la main
aux etats unis c'était des barils qui
avait servi à contenir des harengs qui
sont pas tellement meilleures que le
pétrole n'est pas pire non plus et donc
on s'est dit on va mettre le pétrole là
dedans c'est le truc qu'on a sous la
main et donc on va compter le pétrole le
baril c'est la raison historique pour
laquelle on a ce système métrique très
particulier dans le dans le pétrole
donc c'était un truc liquide on voyait à
peu près ce que c'était et puis avec le
temps on s'est rendu compte que d'un
gisement de pétrole on pouvait faire
sortir d'autres choses
il ya du gaz qui est dissout dans le
pétrole alors le méthane on ne met pas
avec le pétrole mais il ya des gens qui
comptent avec le pétrole du gaz qui sort
du gisement de pétrole qui s'appelle de
l'éthane c-26 totalement du pétrole et
du propane et du butane
donc c'est des hydrocarbures saturés c2
c3 c4 aujourd'hui vous avez des
statistiques dans lesquelles ces compter
avec le pétrole alors ça porte un nom
particulier c2 c3 c4 ça s'appelle des
liquides de gaz ou natural gas liquids
pourquoi ça s'appelle des liquides de
gaz alors que l'état n'est pas liquide à
température et pression ambiante
parce que dans les usines de séparation
des produits gazeux entre eux on
comprime et ont refroidi et ont fait de
la distillation cryogénique en gros
c'est à dire que le méthane et le
dernier truc qui reste gazeuse c'est
comme ça qu'on les évacue
et on fractionne et tous les autres
deviennent liquide et on les évacue
comme ça également alors les vikings de
gaz vous pouvez en avoir dans le pétrole
c'est des molécules dissoudre dans le
pétrole qui ne sont pas du méthane mais
vous en avez également plaint dans le
gaz
tous les réservoirs de gaz qui ont été
formés par des réservoirs de pétrole qui
se sont enfouis sous terre et où le
pétrole s'est fractionné sont en général
des réservoirs de gaz qu'on appelle une
ide c'est à dire que vous avez du
méthane dedans mais vous avez aussi du
butane et du propane et de l'état donc
ces produits qu'on extrait avec le gaz
sont comptés avec le pétrole
l'avenir est ce que ça vaut la peine de
passer deux minutes sur le sujet quand
vous verrez le graphe suivant vous
verrez que oui après vous avez également
sortant avec le gaz des produits qu'on
appelle des condensats et qui sont des
chaînes carbonées qui vont en gros de
ses cinq as et 8
donc c'est un peu plus léger que les
produits que les produits distillés
standard que vous sortez de raffinerie
et qui viennent également avec le gaz
alors cela en général on les compte avec
le pétrole brut c'est très compliqué de
trouver des statistiques dans lesquelles
ces discriminer du pétrole brut
alors voilà les statistiques de l'
agence américaine qui s'appelle energy
in formation et jean si elle vous donne
la production mondiale de pétrole en
discriminant brut et condensat donc le
pétrole qui sort sous forme liquide et
les condensats puis les liquides de gaz
donc c2 c3 c4 puis les biocarburants
mais quand vous regardez les
statistiques de bp statistical review
que j'utilise aussi assez souvent eux
ils agrègent les trois et vous appelle
ça le troll donc vous pouvez augmenter
la production de pétrole avec du pétrole
brut qui diminue des liquides de gaz qui
augmente et des biocarburants qui
augmente chez bp ça s'appelle toujours
augmentation du pétrole bon ça se
discute un peu parce que si on veut
avoir une attribution des causses clair
et bien comprendre qui est en train de
se passer
ça se discute est tout à fait à la fin
de cet exposé je vous montrerai
également une discrimination qui ne va
que jusqu'en 2013 malheureusement
et pas plus récents entre le brut et les
condensats là vous verrez que ça donne
encore une image différente ce que vous
arrivez avoir facilement sur 7
sur ce graphique c'est que si vous
regardez le pétrole brut
il ya une longue période là qui a
démarré en 2005 ça doit vous rappeler un
petit quelque chose avec la crise de
2008 où ça n'augmente quasiment plus et
que l'augmentation des années récentes
en fait elle est moins rapide que
l'augmentation que vous avez eue sur la
même période des liquides de gaz donc en
fait une partie de l'augmentation de la
production dite de pétrole quand vous
utilisez les statistiques de bp ou de l'
agence internationale de l'énergie il
utilise en général de la même les mêmes
stats il la même nomenclature et bien y
mettre dans production de pétrole
les liquides de gaz donc si vous avez
une production de pétrole qui baisse et
une production de gaz qui augmente
vous pouvez très bien avoir une
production peu de professions pétrole
brut qui baisse et une production de gaz
qui augmente
vous pouvez très bien vous retrouver à
l'arrivée avec la production de pétrole
augmente
oui non non non c'est des produits qui
ont une valeur en tant que tel l'état ne
sert de base pour la pétrochimie aussi
de même que le propane de même que alors
le butane sert directement si vous allez
faire du camping ou bien mais on cherche
à les séparer du méthane dans le gaz
absolument pas ce que vous avez des
spécifications dans les appareils qui
utilisent le gaz par exemple votre
cuisinière si vous avez une cuisinière à
gaz
elle n'est pas configuré pour brûler un
gaz dans lequel vous avez une teneur
variable de butane et de propane et
butane
vous avez une spécification ça doit être
du métal dur à 99,2 par combien de neuf
derrière
et donc c'est pour ça qu on épure les
produits et par ailleurs on les épures
aussi parce qu'ils ont osé d'utilisation
particulière en chimie organique et donc
que ça de la valeur à cause de ça
là on revient à ce que à la question qui
a été posée tout à l'heure vous avez ici
quelques ordres de grandeur pour
comparer la matière organique de ceux
qui a vécu sur terre de ce qui est
totalement en parle pas de ce qu'a vécu
chauffeur de ce qui aujourd'hui est
totalement séquestré sous le sol c'est à
dire le kérogène et des masses
respectives de pétrole de charbon etc
donc vous voyez encore une fois que
c'est une petite à chaque fois vous avez
des processus de transformation qui ont
des tout petits rendements vous n'avez
qu'une petite partie qui de ski de ce
qui prend place à une étape données qui
se retrouvent à l'étape d'après voilà
donc c'est juste pour dire que les que
les rendements dans cette affaire sont
sont très faibles
voilà donc à ce stade
quelques quelques éléments de manque
nature donc le pétrole et le gaz se
trouve sous terre dans des réservoirs
l'essentiel du temps ce réservoir c'est
une roche réservoir il arrive que ça et
que ça soit la roche mère elle même
quand c'est une roche mère elle est par
essence sédimentaires parce qu'elle
s'est formée par sédimentation quand
c'est une roche réservoir
c'est également une roche sédimentaire
parce que ça se forment dans les mêmes
bassins dont vous avez du calcaire du
dre du sable qui est poreuse et le
pétrole imprègne les ports en question
et vous avez au plus trois étages de
l'eau du pétrole du gaz
vous pouvez avoir deux étages seulement
du pétrole et de l'eau ou du gaz et de
l'eau quand vous avez du pétrole et de
l'eau vous avez toujours un peu de gaz
qui est dissout dans le pétrole
ce qui veut dire que dans l'exploitation
du pétrole vous devrez toujours séparés
en arrivant à pression atmosphérique du
gaz dissous et du pétrole
le la proportion d'huile dans la roche
ces quelques pour cent à quelques
dizaines de pourcent
mais on va dire que le cas typique c'est
une dizaine de pourcents le pétrole qui
est contenu dans la roche s'appelle du
pétrole en place à cause de la
capillarité c'est à dire que le truc et
visqueux et les porcs tout petit vous ne
ferez jamais sortir la totalité du
pétrole en place une roche réservoir
jamais de même que vous ne ferez jamais
sortir la totalité du pétrole en place
dans une roche mère et donc dans le
monde des pétroliers vous avez un
élément de discussion qui est le taux de
récupération que vous avez dans un
réservoir
bien évidemment quand vous faites une
découverte vous allez essayer d'estimer
ce taux de récupération parce que ça
conditionne la rentabilité économique du
gisement
vous avez mis les infrastructures en
place qui sont ce qu'elles sont plus il
sort de pétrole et mieux vous portez
économiquement pour le reste ça se
discute donc je dis également que plus
est profond et plus la partie de gaz est
élevé que si c'est du pétrole qui s'est
dégradée en surface c'est du bitume et
que si c'est plus jeune que du pétrole
dit autrement eh bien vous avez des
schistes bitumineux des sables bitumeux
du ou du pétrole de roche mère quand
vous trouvez un réservoir de pétrole
conventionnel vous trouvez quelque chose
qui ressemble à ça dit autrement
vous n'avez pas évidemment un coup
d'être pas sous terre comme dans jules
verne
vous n'avez pas un microscope ou une
paire de jumelles qui vous met
directement le réservoir souvenez vous
avez des moyens d'exploration en surface
et pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont déjà
connu et pour ceux d'entre vous qui
connaîtront la première fois que vous
irez vous ferrez cogra fier le ventre
mesdames ou le ventre de votre compagne
messieurs je vous assure que le médecin
vous dira là on voit très bien ça il
faut garder dix rats bus des tur voilà
donc c'est une image qui parle aux
spécialistes
c'est évident que c'est pas une image
qui parle
à chacun d'entre nous donc quand on
essaye de comprendre combien de pétrole
sous terre quand on essaye de comprendre
combien de pétrole sous terre vous avez
quelqu'un mes amis géologue pétrolier
dit en gros ça veut dire que vous faites
le tour d'un hangar ils vont regarder
par le trou de la serrure et vous
essayez de comprendre ce cas dans le
hangar puis à peu près ça le l'idée
qu'il faut garder bon alors maintenant
on sait faire un peu plus que ce qu'on
faisait avant mais enfin quand même
c'est ça vous dit toujours pas
exactement ce qu'il ya dedans et donc
pour savoir
on va faire des trous donc une fois
qu'on a trouvé quelque chose dont on
pense que ça contient du pétrole est
bien en faire tous alors le trou
s'appelle un forage d'exploration
vous allez éventuellement en faire
plusieurs vous voyez que si vous vous y
prenez mal vous pouvez très bien tomber
juste à côté tombé juste à côté du truc
intéressant et vous trompez sur ce que
la roche on tient mais donc vous faites
un trou vous remonter une carotte et
vont regarder ce qui est dedans alors le
pétrole en place une fois que vous
l'avez à peu près qualifier et
quantifier s'appelle une ressource
jamais vous le connaîtrez avec précision
donc à chaque fois là aussi vous voyez
passer dans la presse il y aurait tant
de pétrole dans les sous sols de tels
pays
ça relève d'indication de cette nature
parcellaire extrapolé donc c'est des
gens qui ont fait des calculs de coin de
table en disant imaginons que ce qu'on a
déjà trouvé soit représentatif imaginons
que ceux-ci imaginons que cela mais ça
relève toujours d'un raisonnement de
type modélisation ça peut être une
modélisation rustique et c'est toujours
un événement de type modélisation jamais
vous n'aurez une balance pour allait
peser très exactement le pétrole qui a
dans le sous sol d'un pays
donc si tu en place s'appelle une
ressource et ça dépend évidemment d'un
certain nombre de paramètres que je vous
lis tu là et que vous ne connaîtrez
jamais etc santé avec
avec perfection je rappelle qu'une
découverte ne crée pas du pétrole ça
permet juste de savoir où ils allaient
enfin c'est pareil pour le gaz c'est
pareil pour le charbon est que une fois
que on a découvert
vous avez trois phases possible ou bien
assez découvert et ça reste découvert ou
bien c'est ce qu'on appelle en
développement si vous êtes en train de
créer une exploitation bien cette en
exploitation le bon alors ça c'est un
petit truc un petit un petit disque les
moeurs une fois que vous avez un
réservoir
vous avez trouvé du pétrole que vous
avez commencé à exploiter il est en
général on demande que l'exploitation
est commencé pour parler de réserve
on va parler de réserves prouvées pour
désigner le volume 1 sur lequel vous
pariez votre propre argent veux le dire
comme ça sur le fait que ça va sortir
d'accord donc la réserve trouver ces je
prends l'ingénieur réservoir je le
regarde droit dans les yeux et lui dit
la totalité de ton plan épargne retraite
à on va parier et tu vas me dire combien
il sort de ce fait combien de pétrole il
sort de ce gisement
si tu dois y laisser ton plan épargne
retraite s'ils sont moins que ça donc si
longue le truc le plus conservateur que
vous puissiez dire sur combien de
pétrole va sortir de mon gisement dit
encore autrement c'est une estimation
que vous faites en mettant tous les
paramètres dimensionnant à la valeur la
plus défavorable corps donc celle là
vous allez être le plus conservateur sur
la taille
la porosité la viscosité le taux de
récupération du coup et c'est ça c'est
la réserve prouvée
bien évidemment si vous vous rendez
compte que vous avez sous-estimé la
taille du réservoir
eh bien elle augmente par contre si vous
rendez compte que vous l'avez surestimé
elle diminue quand vous augmenter le
taux de récupération à cause de la
technique vous pouvez augmenter les
réserves prouvées toutes choses égales
par ailleurs
elle peut augmenter avec le prix mais en
fait assez peu parce que la quantité de
pétrole qui va sortir d'un réservoir
dépend avant tout de l'infrastructure de
production que vous allez mettre en
place au début et l'infrastructure que
vous mettez en place au début elle ne
dépend pas de la variation du prix du
pétrole
ensuite donc c'est assez peu sensibles
aux prix pour un gisement qui est déjà
en exploitation par contre le prix
détermine le fait que vous en étiez des
nouveaux tient qu aujourd'hui pour
mettre un nouveau gisement même si c'est
des cochonneries pour la forêt de sables
bitumineux en production au canada c'est
mieux si le prix du baril atteint 80 ou
100 dollars
et si le prix du baril est à 30 $ vous y
allez pas parce que vous êtes sûrs de
perdre votre chemise et bien évidemment
si aucun autre paramètre ne varie la
réserve prouvée diminue avec le temps
puisque avec le temps vous sortez une
partie du pétrole qui est contenue sous
terre donc ça peut pas augmenter la
réserve qui reste vous verrez que ce
truc qui paraît relever du simple bon
sens
on verra un peu plus tard que c'est pas
exactement comme ça que les choses se
passent dans le monde
vous avez une deuxième notion qui est
important dans les réserves
qui est ce qu'on appelle les réserves
ultimes alors les réserves ultimes pour
dire simplement c'est l'intégrale de la
production entre le début et la fin
c'est dérisoire multiples alors ça veut
pour un gisement savez pour le monde
dans son ensemble ça vaut pour un bassin
c'est tout ce qui va sortir du début à
la fin
et comme tout ce qui va sortir du début
à la fin ne varie pas avec le temps
normalement les réserves ultimes ne
varie pas avec le temps par contre
l'appréciation peu varié parce que vous
pouvez vous rendre compte que vous êtes
plantée sur un paramètre dimensionnant
et à un instant donné
ce qui va finir de sortir d'ici à ce
qu'on met une croix sur le gisement
s'appelle les réserves ultimes restantes
dans un monde bien fait je dis bien dans
un monde bien fait les réserves prouvées
à tout instant sont nécessairement
inférieur aux réserves ultimes restantes
d'accord pouvait pas garantir qu'il va
sortir du champ plus que ce qui va
effectivement sortir si vous avez bien
fait votre boulot
si vous avez bien fait votre boulot ce
que vous garantissez la tête sur le
billot
c'est nécessairement inférieur ou égal à
ce qu'il a vraiment sorti
or jusqu au moment où vous allez arrêter
l'exploitation nécessairement comme je
le disais il ya toujours une petite
incertitude dans l'exploitation en fait
les réserves ultimes ne sont
effectivement connu qu'une fois
l'exploitation terminée
alors comme je le disais les réserves
c'est pour un prix mais en fait les
réserves sont assez peu sensibles aux
prix parce que beaucoup d'exploitations
de pétrole conventionnel sont rentables
en gros quel que soit le prix du baril
vous avez ici les coûts techniques
d'extraction je dis bien des coudes
techniques d'extraction du baril dans un
certain nombre de pays dans le monde
alors ce que vous voyez c'est que une
bonne partie du pétrole sort entre 5 et
10 dollars le baril à deux coups
techniques d'extraction alors vous allez
me dire où passent les 80 si ça coûte 10
d'en sortir de terre eh bien ça passe
essentiellement en rente c'est à dire en
impôts taxes et marges intermédiaires
alors les marges intermédiaires c'est
pas le plus important vous avez une
bonne partie du prix du baril qui sont
des taxes payées aux pays producteurs
quand vous exploiter du pétrole vous
avez en général un accord de partage
entre la compagnie qui exploite et le
pays qui détient le pétrole c'est à dire
que total va en irak total négocié avec
les irakiens pour pouvoir avoir le droit
j'appelle un permis d'exploitation pour
avoir le droit d'exploiter du pétrole
qui se trouve là bas et les irakiens
disent à total
ok on est bien d'accord ça va sortir à
10 dollars le baril et bien quand vous
sortez un baril
moi je vous en donne 12 et le reste est
pour moi ça s'appelle un accord de
partage ou bien vous le sortez vous le
vendez et quel que soit le prix du baril
vous m'en donnez les deux tiers et vous
vous démerdez pour gagner de l'argent
sur ce qui reste
mais voilà ce genre de truc qui
s'appelle un accord de partage et donc
l'essentiel de
du prix du baril sur le marché par dans
les pays producteurs et après évidemment
à la pompe il ya encore un supplément de
prix qui part dans les poches du pays
consommateurs vous avez une différence
fondamentale
en ce qui concerne le pétrole dits
conventionnels et le pétrole dits de
roche-mère dans la structure des coûts
dans un gisement de pétrole
conventionnel dont vous avez une roche
poreuse qui contient du pétrole
l'essentiel des coûts a lieu avant que
le premier baril de pétrole ne sorte
vous avez d'abord des coûts
d'exploration et yahoo balade et vos
avions renifleurs un peu partout là et
pour regarder s'il y aurait pas du
pétrole alors en l'occurrence c'est pas
des avions renifleurs c'est comme je le
disais tout à l'heure c'est la sismique
donc ça fonctionne avec des ondes
sonores plus tout un peu plus les
forages etc
et puis si vous vous dites là je sais
qu'il ya du pétrole et qui va sortir
vous devez construire vos
infrastructures d'exploitation vos
infrastructures d'exploitation c'est des
engins qui coûte cher surtout maintenant
que le nouveau pétrole accessible c'est
en général dans des zones dans lequel
c'est compliqué c'est en montagne au
fond de la jungle avec trois millimètres
d'eau sous terre sous les pieds dans la
zone arctique et c'est donc vous allez
construire quelque chose qui vaut très
cher une plateforme d'extraction à terre
ou en mer est derrière votre pétrole va
sortir je sais pas si je vous ai raconté
l'anecdote de kashagan non j'ai pas
raconter l'anecdote de cachalot
l'anecdote de kashagan c'est kashagan
c'est un gisement de pétrole qui allie
qui est se situe au nord de la mer
caspienne et pour lequel le budget
initial de développement c'est-à-dire
d'installation des infrastructures de
production thé et 5 milliards de dollars
et ça s'est terminé à 50
donc ils ont fait x 10 sur le
développement des voies là et parce
qu'il faut faire d'être ce qu'ils sont
extrêmement compliqué et ça gèle l'hiver
bref donc dans ce genre de gisements
conventionnels
une fois que vous avez construit les
infrastructures de production derrière
vous avez des coûts d'exploitation qui
sont raisonnablement mode est ce que
vous voyez
la donc tout ça c'est les coûts en
capitaux de départ ça c'est les coûts
d'exploitation derrière et ça c'est le
profil de production
en ce qui concerne le pétrole de
roche-mère je vais vous montrer dans pas
longtemps j'aurais dû commencer par ça
mais peu importe le profil de production
d'un puits
c'est quasi un d'irak c'est à dire que
après que le puits soit mis en
production il vous faut un mois pour
qu'ils montent au maximum de production
et un an après avoir été mis en
production il est retombé à 50 à 20 % de
son niveau initial
quand donc c'est vraiment un truc où ça
décline extrêmement vite
après avoir été mis en production du
coup pour conserver un approvisionnement
constant en provenance d'un champ il
faut rajouter depuis en permanence et
donc le puits la plateforme n'est plus
devenu un élément de capital c'est
presque devenu un élément de charges
courantes que quand vous exploitez un
champ de pétrole ou de gaz de roche mère
le puits c'est inconcevable vous n'avez
pas un puits comme une infrastructure
comme une plate forme offshore à
quelques milliards de dollars vous
appuyez s'avoue quelques millions de
dollars que vous nous rajouter en
permanence en permanence en permanence
pour garantir le volume qui sort de
votre champ et alors ça ça vous montre
ce que vous avez ici hein c'est qu'en
gros ce qui était des investissements
pour un champ de pétrole conventionnel
devient quelque part de charges
courantes pour des gens qui exploitent
du pétrole de roche-mère est ici vous
avez le profil de production
correspondante
et dès que vous arrêtez de rajouter des
puits en permanence et bien vous suivez
exactement la même chose que le déclin
ici avec quelques charges d'exploitation
résiduelles à cause de cette
particularité du pétrole et du gaz de
roche mère eh bien vous avez cette
bizarrerie aux états unis et qui est un
truc que j'ai toujours pas bien compris
donc je vous livre le résultat brut mais
je ne suis pas capable toujours de vous
livrer l'explication qui est depuis 2012
en moyenne
si vous prenez l'ensemble des
exploitants eh bien les exploitants de
pétrole et de gaz de roche mère aux
états unis perdent de l'argent depuis
ils perdent de l'argent c'est à dire que
chaque année l'argent qu'ils doivent
décaissés pour payer de gens qui vont
faire le puits
c'est plus que l'argent qu'ils vont
gagner avec le pétrole qui sont des
puits alors maintenant ils doivent
également payer non seulement les gens
qui font les puits mais également la
dette croissante qu'ils ont contractés
pour survivre à l'époque où ils ont
commencé à faire les puits donc en gros
au moment où il commence à faire les
puits le pétrole est cher il est à plus
de 100 dollars le baril du coup ils ont
ils s'endettent avec des taux d'intérêt
élevés et maintenant où le pétrole
pendant et maintenant où les coûts
d'exploitation ont quand même baissé
en fait ils ont une telle quantité
d'intérêts à payer que il ya toujours
pas d'argent il arriverait à gagner de
l'argent s'ils avaient plus de dettes
mais ils ont tellement bête qui n'arrive
pas à gagner d'argent non plus donc à
une bizarrerie dans le pétrole de
roche-mère aux états unis c'est la
raison pour laquelle personnellement je
surveille d'assez près ce qui est en
principe assez parce que mon sentiment
c'est que s'il ya une bizarrerie
financière dans ce secteur là il
pourrait y avoir un arrêt assez rapide
de la croissance de la production de
pétrole dans ce secteur et il se trouve
que c'est le seul endroit au monde avec
l'irak où la production de pétrole
continue à croître
donc ce qui est en train de se passer en
ce moment aux états unis dans pétrole de
roche-mère conditionnent l'évolution de
la production mondiale de pétrole
et vous allez voir dans pas longtemps
que ça conditionne à tout petit peu
l'économie mondiale alors revenons à ce
que je disais vous avez donc un endroit
où on pense qu'il ya du pétrole
et selon le fait que vous mettez les
paramètres dimensionnant oui
si j'avais la réponse je l'aurais donné
je le dis moi j'ai pas la réponse
la décision politique des pays de l'opep
qui a que les gens qui couche avec les
décideurs de l'opep qui l'ont vraiment
et encore méfiez-vous beaucoup de ce
qu'il ya dans le journal parce que dans
le journal où il ya de la théorie du
complot à tous les étages
moi je pense que pour avoir une réponse
à ce genre de questions il faut avoir
fréquenté les décideurs en question
pendant dix ans les avoir un peu saoulé
entre la poire et le fromage avoir
recueilli leurs confidences et avoir
fini par arriver à un tout cohérent
tant qu'on n'en est pas là faut être
hyper prudent sur la façon dont on pense
que les choses se passent non mais très
honnêtement je peux vous dire qu'il ya
au moins un cas de figure dans lequel
l'opep a raconté des choses dont je
savais pertinemment qu'elles étaient
fausses
c'est au moment du choc pétrolier de
2005 à 2008 où le l'opep arrêtait pas de
dire le marché est suffisamment
approvisionné n'y a pas de raison d'en
rajouter alors que les prix étaient en
train de s'envoler les gens de l'opep
savez très bien que derrière il y allait
y avoir des variations un peu
désagréable et personnellement je sais
très bien qu'à l'époque il pouvait tout
simplement plus ouvrir les robinets
il y avait pas de robinet et ouvrir six
avec les capacités inemployées de
production taquet et plus donc ce qui se
cachait derrière le fait de dire le
marché est suffisamment approvisionné et
les journaux de répéter le marché est
suffisamment approvisionné
donc moi je ne sais pas ce qu'il ya dans
la tête des dirigeants de l'opep en ce
moment en plus c'est plein de pays et
c'est pas sûr que dans toute la tête de
faim dans toutes les têtes de tous les
dirigeants il ya exactement la même
chose donc je ne sais je ne sais pas la
seule chose que je sais c'est qu'ils
perdent de l'argent et du coup si un
équilibre instable
voilà ça je sais
j'en reviens à ce que disait donc en ce
qui concerne mes réserves
vous avez une approche probabiliste
quand vous d'y mentionner vos réserves
donc c'est un résumé de ce que je viens
de vous dire si vous me paie tous les
paramètres dimensionnant aux plus
conservateurs vous avez ce qu'on appelle
les réserves prouvées
si vous mettez tous les paramètres
dimensionnant à la valeur que vous
estimez la plus probable
vous avez les réserves ultimes si vous
mettez tous les paramètres dimensionnant
à la valeur la plus optimiste possible
vous avez ce qu'on appelle des réserves
iii p mais vous avez à peu près autant
de chance d'avoir ça que de gagner au
loto
en plus quand même d'avoir ça mais pas
beaucoup plus j'ai pas réactualisé ce
graphique qui traîne depuis de
nombreuses années il est juste pour dire
qu'en ce qui concerne le pétrole et le
gaz
la quantité totale de pétrole et de gaz
extractible de terre dans les gisements
dits conventionnels donc là je parle pas
des roches mères est à peu près connu
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que le reste à
découvrir et vous verrez plus tard que
l'on découvre pas grand chose le reste à
découvrir dans ce domaine là aujourd'hui
est considéré comme étant très faibles
donc le pétrole et le gaz extractives
sur terre aujourd'hui ne rentre quand
dans deux catégories pour l'essentiel ce
qu'on a déjà extrait ça on est sûr c est
extractible est ce qu'on n'a pas encore
extrême et qui est contenu dans des
endroits qui sont déjà localisés évaluer
et quantifier etc c'est dans l'un ou
dans l'autre quelque chose que je jeu
alors que pour le charbon pardon c'est
pas du tout le cas pour le charbon il ya
une beaucoup plus grosse incertitude sur
ce qui pourrait être contenue dans des
endroits qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui
dans les réserves
rappelez vous que la chasse au pétrole
ressemble à la chasse aux oeufs de
pâques pour ceux d'entre vous qui en ont
déjà cherché dans le jardin quand vous
cherchez les autres packs en général
vous allez trouver en premier les plus
gros et les moyens bloquer le pétrole
c'est pareil quand vous cherchez du
pétrole vous trouvez en premier les plus
gros et les moins bien planqué ce qui
veut dire qu'avec le temps il vous reste
à trouver les plus petits et les vieux
planqué c'est à dire là il n'y a pas
grand chose ou bien s'ils sont gros
ils sont extrêmement bien planqués et
s'ils sont extrêmement bien planqué ça
veut dire que en termes de coûts
d'exploitation ça va être cher alors les
réserves de charbon j'y viendrai à la
fin de cette présentation vous verrez où
se trouve le charbon là ce que vous avez
donc en rouge vous avez le charbon déjà
consommé en jeu vous avez les réserves
qui sont quelque qui sont déclarés
exactement sur le même principe que les
réserves pétrolières normalement crc
dans des trucs du genre exploitation est
ce que vous pouvez être vous êtes sûr de
sortir appris les techniques constant et
le reste eh bien c'est la barre
d'erreurs on va dire donc ça peut être
n'importe où entre la et là le reste
c'est le charbon qui n'est pas dans les
réserves et donc dans diverses sources
pense que ça pourrait être extrait si on
avait envie de le faire et vous avez des
chiffres qui sont pas du tout
concordants donc vous avez une très très
grosse barre d'erreurs sur ce qui ce qui
reste en dehors des réserves
en ce qui concerne le pétrole et le gaz
conventionnel
vous avez ici un histogramme qui vous
donne l'historique des découvertes dans
le monde depuis le début du 20e siècle
ce que vous voyez sur cette histoire âme
de manière manifeste c'est que depuis en
gros
l'année de ma naissance bon vous
n'existiez même pas à peine sous forme
de vos sites
eh bien les découvertes de pétrole et de
gaz ont décliné donc les découvertes de
pétrole et de gaz contenus dans des
gisements dits conventionnels
un des roches poreuses imprégné pas des
roches mères décline depuis maintenant
plus de cinquante ans c'est une autre
façon de dire que vous avez une tendance
lourde qui est à l'oeuvre et que la
probabilité que demain matin on découvre
un énorme oeuf de pâques dont on n'avait
vraiment pas idée jusqu'à maintenant
veut ne pas trop compter dessus voilà
une autre un autre graphique qui vous
dit exactement la même chose et voilà
encore un autre graphique qui vous dit
exactement la même chose
et alors ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'est à partir de ces
découvertes
si au moment où vous découvrez vous avez
correctement évalué la quantité de
pétrole extractible il sortira
effectivement ce que vous pensez avoir
découvert parce qu'en général les
découvertes se comptent en pétrole
extractible le plus probable d'un camp
de p1 si vous n'avez pas de chance il en
sortira de sa et si vous avez beaucoup
de chance il en sortira sans les régions
du monde étant de mieux en mieux connus
au fur et à mesure qu'elles sont de plus
en plus exploré ce que vous voyez sur ce
graphique c'est le cumul des découvertes
en randonnée en fonction du cumul des
puits d'exploration qui ont été forés
est ce que vous voyez c'est que toutes
ses courbes ont une asymptote
horizontale
car moment vous avez tous découvert
pourrait bien rajouter des puits pour
enfin vous pouvez bien rajouter des
puits d'exploration il ya plus rien à
découvrir donc vous découvrirez un et
vous voyez également que la découverte
marginal
tend à s'amenuiser au cours du temps là
vous avez un zoom sur le moyen-orient
parce que sur la courbe précédentes vous
pouvez avoir l'impression que c'est ça
continuer à monter en flèche
en fait si vous désormais ça donne ça
ils sont que le moyen-orient c'est un
endroit où on a découvert des champs
super géant dont le plus grand champ
j'avais découvert au monde gaouar qui
ces 100 milliards de barils à sa
découverte 100 milliards de barils ces
trois ans de consommation actuel donc
c'est quand même donc brochand et
donc le au moyen-orient c'est exactement
comme le reste donc absolument encore
des trucs à découvrir si on cherche à
supposer qu'on doit chercher à cause du
climat mais
on a découvert
l'essentiel ce que vous voyez également
sur ce graphique c'est que l' envie de
chercher et très corrélés aux prix du
pétrole
donc vous avez ici la quantité d'argent
qu'on a investi dans les découvertes
je dis bien dans les découvertes dans le
jeu d'exploration est ici vous avez le
prix du baril en noir donc vous voyez
que au moment où le prix du baril monte
on cherche avec plus de frénésie plus le
temps ça ne veut pas dire qu'on trouve
plus puisque vous avez vu sur les
courbes d'avant que les découvertes
avaient tendance à diminuer avec le
temps de la raison pour laquelle les
découvertes baisse c'est pas parce que
c'est feignante pétroliers ont embauché
des feignants d'ingénieur des mines ont
arrêté de chercher et ne trouve plus
rien c'est juste parce qu'à un moment
vous avez trouvé tous les autres packs
dans le jardin et donc vous pouvez
chercher avec frénésie vous trouverez
rien et vous allez ici quelque chose qui
vous dit à peu près la même la même
chose en fille qui vous dit à peu près
la même chose
vous avez en rouge en pour ce qu'on
appelle les mehdorn
ils sont en fait les compagnies
internationales côté les dépenses
d'exploration et envers la production de
ces mêmes sociétés et donc vous voyez
que c'est pas parce qu'elles ont investi
plus que la production a suivi en fait
elles ont surtout investi pour essayer
de limiter le déclin c'est plutôt comme
ça qu'il faut voir les choses
par ailleurs les puits d'exploration ont
tendance à valloire de plus en plus cher
oui
au temps qui passe
m
ça c'est une partie de la réponse
mais pas que une autre partie de la
réponse c'est que quand le prix montent
vous vous dites si j'arrive à trouver
quelque chose ça encore plus de valeur
qu'avant et donc les deux effets
conjugués qui sont à la fois la hausse
du prix qui elle même a été déclenchée
par une insuffisance d'offres donc la
hausse du prix des déclenchée par une
insuffisance d'offres donc vous avez
deux éléments effectivement qui vous
pousse l'insuffisance d'offres vous dit
quand même si je trouverai un truc ça
serait bien parce que l'offre jeu
pourrait l'augmenter et par ailleurs
comme ça vaut cher si je trouve quelque
chose c'est tout bénef
et donc vous allez chercher des trucs
qui sont un peu plus marginaux que si le
prix est bas si le prix est bas vous
vous dites c'est même pas la peine que
je cherche pas de façon si je trouve
quelque chose ça coûtera plus cher à
exploiter que le bénéfice que je vais en
retirer et à chaque fois que le prix
montent
ben vous avez des frange marginale qui
deviennent potentiellement intéressantes
et vous dites si jaya 3 quelque chose là
éventuellement ça vaut le coup donc vous
augmenter les budgets de l'exploration
oui pardon alors vous avez dans le prix
du pétrole
un phénomène d'oscillation qui est liée
au fait que le cycle de développement
d'un projet et le cycle de réponse du
consommateur ne sont pas accordés vous
avez un décalage de phase et donc ce
décalage de phase vous induire une
oscillation du prix du pétrole
dit autrement alors je vais comme c'est
une oscillation n'y a pas de début et de
fin donc je prends l'histoire à un
moment donné à un moment donné le prix
est ce qu'il est et la consommation
escalettes
vous avez une consommation qui a envie
d'augmenter un peu à ce moment le prix
augmente
à ce moment les pétroliers se disent
comme le prix augmente
eh bien je vais investir un peu plus
pour augmenter l'offre à ce moment
l'offre augmente un peu plus un peu
violent mais comme l offre n augmente
pas tout de suite
le prix du pétrole continue d'augmenter
sauf qu'à ce moment le conservateur se
dit bon ça commence vraiment à valloire
cherche à faire je vais faire un peu
attention donc la hausse de l'offre sur
la hausse de la demande se modère voir
la demande baisse un peu et au moment où
les nouveaux projets arrivent sur le
marché
à ce moment vous avez une offre qui
devient un peu surabondante
à ce moment le prix se casse la gueule à
ce moment les pétroliers s'arrête
d'investir à ce moment ça resserre
l'offre mais comme le prix se casse la
gueule le consommateur se dit yamgname
je vais en consommer un peu plus et donc
les deux phénomènes aussi en opposition
de phase ou en décalage de phase
alors ça ne vous dit pas quel est le
volume cette histoire par contre ça vous
dit que livré à lui même
le prix aussi j'ai envie de dire aux
rythmes de réponse du consommateur et au
rythme de développement des nouveaux
projets alors dans le shale oil comme la
réponse est beaucoup plus rapide
parce qu'en fait faux rien puis ça va
très vite le phénomène chez l'homme va
probablement raccourcir la longueur
d'onde de l'oscillation alors c'est mon
pari en tout cas donc ça c'est pas une
certitude mais en tout cas c'est une
hypothèse que je suis raisonnablement
prêt à apprendre comme hypothèse de
travail
pendant donc ici vous avez le coût d'un
puits d'exploration et vous voyez que
c'est quelque chose qui a tendance à
augmenter avec la difficulté du terrain
dans lequel vous avez besoin d'aller les
regarde alors en fait je vous ai dit
tout ça vous avez donc des réserves et
ses réserves sont déclarés à la fois par
des compagnies est à la fois par des
pays
la raison pour laquelle les compagnies
déclarent les réserves quand elle
déclare ce qui concerne à peu près 10%
des opérateurs pétroliers dans le monde
c'est en général parce qu'elles sont
cotées en bourse à ce moment vous avez
une obligation de communiquer le montant
vous réserves prouvées notamment au
titre de la régulation américaines de la
security and exchange commission
quand vous êtes un pays notamment de
l'opep la prémédication de vos réserves
sert à arbitrer les quotas de production
le pays de l'apec donc il ya un
indicateur qui enfin comment dire cette
donnée a une importance assez forte pour
les pays de l'opep
parce que c'est avec les réserves
prouvées que vous vous répartissez les
quotas de production qui autrement si
l'opep dit je vais produire tant au
total c'est au prorata des réserves de
chacun oui alors là en général quand il
s'agit des pays tu as un pays type
argentin argentine pardon en fait c'est
les réserves des opérateurs
internationaux opérant en argentine qui
publient leurs réserves et qui sont
agrégées pour faire les réserves de
l'argentine
c'est comme ça que ça marche mais quand
je vais vous montrer les réserves
saoudiennes c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche c'est l'état saoudien qui publie
les réserves vous allez voir ça va bien
alors dans un oui alors l'opep c'est une
organisation qui a été créé pour cartes
elysées la production de pétrole
donc c'est un cartel qui a été créé et
qui sert à limiter délibérément la
quantité de pétrole disponible sur le
marché en cette cible en des quotas de
production c'est à dire que l'opep dit
ben voilà pour les trois années qui
viennent pour l'année qui vient pour les
deux années qui viennent on va produire
temps et pas plus qu autant ces
limitations et ils ne paient pas fait ça
historiquement pour stabiliser les cours
du pétrole ce qui du reste a très bien
marché puisque le prix du pétrole je
voulais montrer aux derniers cours
pendant un siècle
entre 1870 et 1970 n'a pas varié à 20
dollars constants le baril chez les
dollars de l'époque savaria en dollars
constants qui restait avant donc ses
salopettes donc c'est essentiellement
des pays du moyen-orient
plus tôt vers le venezuela dont enfin
brochet les pays exportateurs opep ça
veut dire organisation des pays
exportateurs de pétrole
et en anglais ça se dit opecst ce qui si
ma mémoire est bonne signifie
orgueilleuse exporting countries
donc c'est alors dans gens réservent
donc je vous ai dit tout à l'heure les
réserves prouvées diminue avec le temps
toutes choses égales par ailleurs
augmente avec les découvertes augmente
avec les réévaluations etc ce qui veut
dire que quand vous regardez les
réserves d'une zone
il n'y a pas de raisons particulières
sauf coup de chance une année qu'elle
soit constante d'une année sur l'autre
donc une évolution normale des réserves
d'un pays ça ressemble à ça ça monte ça
descend ça monte ça descend donc là on
peut supposer qu'il ya eu une découverte
là il ya eu deux ans d'exploitation sans
rien là il ya d'exploitation sans rien
là il ya une découverte mais petit la ja
d'exploitation sans rien où on a
éventuellement des classes et même une
réserve qui et c'est là on découvre des
tas de trucs malgré l'exploit est
d'accord c'est ça l'histoire normal des
réserves c'est que ça monte et ça
descend alors voilà un pays où ça monte
et ça descend brou regret à dire à part
que le fait que ça monte et ça descend
voilà votre pays où ça monte et ça
descend drummond très bien ça monte et
ça descend
voilà la norvège donc c'est monté très
vite après les chocs pétroliers parce
que la mer du nord était mise en
production dans les années 70 et puis à
un moment ça passe un maximum puis ça
descend là le prix très élevés du
pétrole des dernières années a relancé
de l'exploration ami a conduit par dont
les norvégiens à mettre en oeuvre des
techniques de récupération assistée qui
font que on augmente un peu le volume qu
on considère qu'on va récupérer
voilà un pays qui a aussi une évolution
normale j'ai envie de dire
malheureusement pour lui qui est le
royaume uni voilà un pays dans lequel on
augmente parce qu'on avait pas de
découvrir puis ça diminue etc
voilà les états unis donc ça c'est
l'apparition chez l'oreille et puis
voilà un premier pays du moyen-orient
s'avance à pas forcés les russes
enfin c'est le
c'est l'ancienne urss ça c'est déjà un
peu plus bizarre oui qu'est ce que c'est
que ce machin là qu'est ce que c'est que
ce machin là
bon c'est un peu bizarre quand même
alors là les pays de l'ancienne union
soviétique sont des pays
c'est ça que ça veut dire c'est yes
ainsi l'ancienne union soviétique sont
des pays dans lesquels en particulier la
russie
vous n'avez pas accès commodément à des
chiffres sur les réserves
donc voilà donc vous avez accès à ce
qu'ils vous disent et puis ça s'arrête à
peu près de lisieux la vuelta mais les
yeux là ça devrait suffire biens dont
ils sont assis sur un tas d'or
donc qu'est ce qui se passe alors en
fait il se passe que le pétrole qui
conduit à l'extraordinaire augmentation
des réserves ici c'est un pétrole
particulier extra lourd qui ressemble à
du miel et qui se situe dans le bassin
du fleuve qui s'appelle l'orénoque
donc c'est un peu folle qui ne
s'expliquent pas avec des techniques
classiques
en fait il faut que je fais pour qu'ils
deviennent suffisamment fluide pour
qu'il remonte par les puits ça demande
une dépense d'énergie sur place et
surtout des infrastructures qui sont
très capitalistique qui ne sont pas
mises en oeuvre à large échelle
aujourd'hui dieu autrement alors que le
venezuela est en train vous allez le
voir dans pas longtemps de vider ses
baignoires de pétrole conventionnel
ils ont trouvé une énorme baignoire d'un
truc qui lui va se vider beaucoup plus
difficilement et ils disent c'est pas
grave les deux balles donc je réévaluent
mes réserves
en rajoutant la baignoire qui va être
très difficile a vidé mais qui est très
grosse
donc là se pose la question de savoir si
ça c'est orthodoxe dire autrement si
vous avez un énorme héritage dont le
testament dit que vous ne pourrez
dépenser 15 euros par jour
qu'est ce que ça vaut est ce que ça vaut
effectivement tout l'argent que vous
avez sur le compte en banque ou est ce
que vous dites non raisonnablement tout
ce que je compte 6 1 euro par jour d'ici
à ce que je meure donc 365 fois 60 et on
s'arrête là moi j'ai envie de dire c'est
plutôt la deuxième option du envie de
prendre et les vénézuéliens disent non
s'il ya un milliard sur le compte en
banque même si je peux dépenser 15 euros
par jour je compte un milliard
vous voyez que c'est une affaire de
conventions donc la convention choisi
vous pousser à vers des sommets on
aurait très bien pu ne pas pousser vers
les sommets
voilà maintenant un des premiers pays du
moyen-orient en l'occurrence l'iran
alors vous voyez ici quelques marches
d'escalier vous voyez que les réserves
de ce pays qui sont pourtant exploité
depuis des dizaines d'années ne font que
croître et embellir
donc c'est quand même génial ce truc-là
harry potter ferait pas mieux vous avez
du pétrole sous terre vous en faites
sortir une partie on vous dit combien il
reste à la fin de l'année plus haut et à
la fin de l'année prochaine plus ah bon
et à la fin de l'année prochaine encore
plus bon alors vous pourriez vous dirai
ce que j'ai découverte de réponse non
les découvertes majeures dans ce pays
sont toutes très ancienne qu'est ce qui
s'est passé cette année là eh bien il
sait pas c'est que à cette époque l'opep
existe déjà et vous avez ce qu'on
appelle le contre-choc pétrolier dont
vous vous rappelez dans les années 70 le
prix du bahreïn explose dans les années
80 il se casse la gueule
le prix du baril se cassant la figure
les recettes à l'exportation des pays
pétroliers se casse la figure aussi un
jour on avait demandé au ministre du
pétrole d'arabie saoudite qu'elle était
le bon prix du baril a et il avait
répondu c'est le prix qui équilibre le
budget de l'arabie saoudite
non c'est pas une blague dans ces pays
les recettes à l'exportation liées au
pétrole constitue une part dominante
voire massive des recettes budgétaires
donc vous avez le contrechoc
au prix du baril qui est divisée par 3
donc à ce moment vous avez vos recettes
budgétaires qui se sont divisés enfin
les recettes à l'exportation sont
divisées par trois à ce moment vous avez
un truc qui marche très bien pour que ça
augmente ou dita est en fait j'ai plus
de réserves que ce que j'avais dit et
comme les quotas de production sont au
prorata des réserves instantanément vous
vous retrouvez avec le droit de produire
plus et donc de gagner plus comment
élire un président passe et c'est
exactement ce que fait l'iran à ce
moment là donc craque je commentais
réserve en charge et plus l'histoire en
tête je sais que quoi
puis après vous voyez par quelle que
soit la quantité de pétrole qui sort de
terre façon c'est toujours la même chose
en voilà un autre voilà c'est pareil
alors même histoire même punition au
même moment il fait exactement la même
chose
et puis après vous voyez c'est des trucs
qui sont totalement flat pendant des
années et des années
donc si on est donc si on croit la
manière dont on définit les réserves ça
veut dire que dans ces pays la cpi l'a10
la manière dont j'ai ré évaluer mes
réserves avec mes découvertes mes
réévaluation et c'est très exactement la
quantité de pétrole qui est sorti de
méchants l'année dernière alors une
année je veux bien
enfin six ou sept années de suite ça
commence à devenir plus bizarre après
voici la libye alors voilà c'est
exactement pareil ici c'est complètement
choc est alors surtout regardez vous
voyez la totalité des réserves atteint
aujourd'hui 50 milliards de barils
alors que là on était à 20 et sachant
que dans l'intervalle on a fait sortir
10 7 et qui a pas eu de découverte
majeure dans le pays
bon est-ce que ce truc là c'est du vent
dit autrement est-ce que c'est du flan
politique totale est par ailleurs la
production de la libye aujourd'hui et
basse même très basse je lui jugé dans
les graphiques derrière ou est ce que ça
vaut quelque chose et puis alors là on
commence à arriver dans le grandiose
ça c'est les émirats arabes unis alors
vous voyez effets du contrôle choc
pétrolier voilà et là ça reste stable
vous voyez donc on est resté stable à
100 milliards de barils
alors que dans le même temps on en a
fait sortir 30 de terre et qui a pas eu
de découverte majeure
bon qu'est ce que ça vaut un truc comme
ça
même motif même punition
l'arabie saoudite et vous voyez ils sont
à 250 alors que dans constants alors que
dans l'intervalle ils en ont fait sortir
110 alors qu'est ce que je suis en train
de vous dire que je suis dit je suis en
train de vous dire qu'en ce qui concerne
les pays du moyen-orient à part
éventuellement le patron de la compagnie
pétrolière
et encore c'est pas sûr parce que ses
ingénieurs terrain qu'on la formation
primaire c'est le mec qui se baladent
sur le terrain qui sait combien de pays
reste de pétrole puis par puis 1 donc à
part le patron de la compagnie
pétrolière
et encore c'est pas sûr je pense que à
peu près personne française qui reste
exactement
vous avez un ancien numéro deux de la
compagnie nationale saoudienne a dit un
jour dans un colloque à un truc est
totalement passé sous le radar dans la
grande presse il ya dix mois je pense
qu'il ya 300 milliards de barils au
moyen-orient qui n'existe pas dans les
chiffres qui sont publiés
c'est à dire en gros la totalité des
réserves saoudiennes dis moi je pense
que ça existe pas d obligation parce que
de quel droit
depuis le traité de westphalie qui rend
les états souverains
vous acceptez que quelqu'un vienne
mettre son nez dans vos affaires
si vous acceptez pas vous acceptez pas
de même que vous n'avez strictement
aucun opérateur international qui vient
mettre son nez dans le sous sol français
en disant je vais dire mieux que le brgm
ski alors sous sol français les passants
oui
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure en ce qui
concerne les pays de l'opep
vous avez pas entendu pour une fois vous
demanderez à vos copains les états unis
j'ai pas dit qu'ils mentaient sur la
réserve non non pas les états unis non
non vous garderez le support aux états
unis oui publie alors ceux qui publient
les entités qui publient leurs réserves
parce qu'elles sont cotées en bourse à
l'évidence c'est pas les pays les
entités qui publient leurs réserves
parce qu'elles sont cotées en bourse
c'est les opérateurs pétroliers
internationaux donc exxon mobil shell
etc
alors les productions que je vous
rapporte là ne viennent pas des réserves
là je vous à part dans les réserves que
je vous rapporte la sont soit celle
publiée par les pays quand ils sont
membres de l'opep donc par exemple
l'arabie saoudite soit celles qui sont
l'agrégat des réserves prouvées déclarés
par les opérateurs internationaux
présents dans les pays quand il s'agit
de pays ouvert normaux est ce que vous
avez toujours un opérateur international
qui traînent dans le coin qui participe
à l'exploitation du champ souvent les
chansons opéré par plusieurs opérateurs
qui se disent entre eux et donc à ce
moment il y en a au moins un qui est
obligé de dire dentelle challah ya tant
de réserve et du reste ma part est en
route pour cent dans mes comptes je
compte en est à ce moment les réserves
des pays sont obtenus par agrégats des
réserves publiées par les opérateurs du
pays
prix ce n'est pas capable de retracer
les réserves à partir de tout ce qui est
dit déclaré parler parce que vous avez
plein de pays dans lequel les opérateurs
n'ont qu'une partie d'exploitation par
exemple en arabie saoudite l'opérateur
qui contrôlent l'exploitation pétrolière
du pays c'est saudi aramco samedi aramco
d'à peu près aucune aucun gisement
partager avec un opérateur international
donc ce système ne marche que dans les
pays dans lesquels la totalité ou la
quasi-totalité des gisements sont opérés
ou partager avec un opérateur
international
les chats ne concerne pas typiquement
les pays du golfe pour l'essentiel oui
donc ses retombées donc il ya un jeu qui
est les gens se réunissent et puis il is
to attend tu attends tu attends toi
temps alors en fait c'est toi tant au
prorata des réserves prouvées donc qui
fixe les quotas les pays eux-mêmes une
fois qu'ils ont déclaré des réserves
prouvées c'est probablement la raison
soit dit en passant pour laquelle ce
truc là ne baisse pas parce que baisser
ses réserves prouvées
c'est automatiquement baisser sa part
revendiqué dans la production de
l'ensemble la manière dont ça se passe
assez clope et fixe un quota global donc
l'opep dit je vais alimenter le marché à
hauteur de 30 millions de barils par
jour
et une fois que l'opep à 10 et 30
millions pour la totalité à ce moment
entre en jeu le la répartition au
prorata des réserves prouvées c'est dans
ce sens là que ça se passe
donc d'abord collégialement l'opep dit
ça sera 30 31 29 28 42 et ensuite ils se
répartissent house un des pays avec les
réserves de chacun tu le ressens ça que
ça marche
alors une fois que j'ai additionner les
réserves avancée par enfin inventorié au
titre de chaque pays
voilà ce que ça donne donc c'est quand
même merveilleux depuis qu'on a commencé
à faire sortir du pétrole de terre
jamais les réserves prouvées ont baissé
quand même un truc merveilleux voilà
donc une autre manière de dire ça et
vous aller confronter sa après à ce que
je vais vous montrer sur un statement
enfin une déclaration de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie qui date
d'il ya quelques mois et vous verrez que
ça pose quand même question
donc ça c'est les contrôles contre
charles qui est le moyen-orient qui
augmente fortement
ça c'est la découverte des sables
bitumineux au canada mais c'est la
grosse baignoire avec un tout petit
robinet dont je parlais tout à l'heure
ça c'est la découverte des extra lourd
au venezuela c'est une autre grosse
baignoire avec un tout petit robinet
quand vous regardez les réserves
estimées donc là c'est des experts du
secteur qui disent voilà ce qui se vend
à peu près où ce que je reconstitue etc
vous voyez que la première compagnie
internationale qui figurent dans ce
classement c'est exxon qui est là toutes
les autres c'est les compagnies
nationales auxquelles on a attribué les
réserves de leur pays mais didi
autrement vous voyez que l'essentiel des
réserves prouvées détenus dans le monde
sont des réserves prouvées détenus par
des opérateurs nationaux de pays dans
lesquels il n'y a pas
libre un libre accès aux champs
pétroliers juste avec une question
d'argent et les réserves qui sont
déclarés par les opérateurs pétroliers
aux côtés en bourse en fait c'est une
toute petite partie là international
company c'est une toute petite partie 2
de ce qui est détenu dans ses réserves
prouvées au sens où on dit qu'elles
doivent être comptés mais comme je le
disais tout à l'heure ça veut pas dire
que ça va sortir effectivement c'est des
gens qui disent qu'ils ont respecté les
règles pour établir les réserves
prouvées mais comme pour revenir à la
question qui a été posée tout à l'heure
il n'y a pas de vérification par des
tiers assermenté venant d'un autre pays
mais tant leur nez dans le truc en
vidant oui je suis d'accord alors les
réserves prouvées n'arrête pas
d'augmenter maintenant question est ce
que ça veut dire que la production ne va
pas arrêter d'augmenter alors là on peut
dire non on est sûr que non grâce à des
matches que vous avez apprise quand vous
étiez jeune je me rappelle plus de quel
on m'a dit que c'était correct de rôle
mais je ne sais plus si c'est exactement
suivre un jour il faudrait je regarde je
sais que ce théorème peut démontrer en
tant que tel donc vous avez sous terre
du pétrole qui met n'importe quoi entre
quelques dizaines de millions d'années
et quelques centaines de millions
d'années à se former
soit dit en passant ce que je vais vous
dire à partir de maintenant s'applique
également aux minerais de cuivre autant
talent au vanadium au tac stand au
molybdène aux chromes et alain dionne
dit autrement dès que vous avez sous
terre une ressource dont le stock de
départ est donné une fois pour toutes ce
que je vais considérer en première
approximation être le cas du pétrole à
l'échelle des temps historiques
dit autrement d'ici à ce que la
civilisation industrielle des hommes
s'éteignent on va dire que ça va prendre
n'importe quoi entre quelques décennies
et quelques milliers d'années et bien le
stock de pétrole ne se réveillera pas de
manière significative
donc je considère que j'ai un inventaire
de départ en ce qui concerne le pétrole
sous terre qui est donnée une fois pour
toutes alors quand il est donnée une
fois pour toutes
vous êtes d'accord avec moi que si la
quantité de départ est donné une fois
pour toutes je ne peux pas avoir une
extraction au cours du temps qui sont
indéfiniment croissante
ça ça me donne une intégrale qui est
infinie or si mon stock de départ est
donné une fois pour toutes ça veut dire
que l'intégrale de ma production elle
est nécessairement fini en fait elle est
bordée et sa bande supérieure c'est le
stock extractives de départ d'accord
toujours très simple on est d'accord
qu'on fait on ne peut même pas avoir une
extraction qui soit à défilement
constante
donc on peut même pas rester
indéfiniment au même niveau même ça
c'est pas possible
en fait le théorème dont je ne me
rappelle plus exactement du nom s'ils
tentaient qu'il se démontre comme tel
c'est que quand vous avez une fonction
qui est positive et intégrale et
intégrables euh pardon entre mansle
affiliées plus infinie
dit autrement vous savez que tu as une
valeur fille dit eh bien vous pouvez
démontrer que sa valeur moyenne sur
n'importe quel intervalle pendule nuls
à moins d'un fini nul à + l'infini et
passe par un maximum absolu entre les
deux c'est assez simple en fait à
démontrer cela démontrait bien par
l'absurde alors la valeur moyenne de ma
production sur un intervalle nodules
c'est par exemple la production annuelle
la production annuelle est déjà une
intégrale donc c'est déjà une moyenne
oui d'accord oui ou non
d'accord à une moyenne c'est une
intégrale / le un horizon de temps de
glisser sur vidal et ses moyens donc la
production annuelle de pétrole la
production de pétrole étant une fonction
positive et intégrables je peux faire un
cumul et ça ne peut aller que dans un
seul sens un peu te sortir de sous terre
pour aller vers la surface
donc c'est positif et intégrables et
bien la production annuelle de pétrole
est nul
à moins l'infini ça se démontre assez
facilement ce sera nul à puce l'infini
et passera par un maximale celui entre
les deux dit autrement je viens de vous
démontrer que en ce qui concerne la
production de pétrole comme de gaz comme
de charbon comme domina cuivre comme de
minerai de fer comme de diamants comme
d'or comme d'argent comme de gallium
comme d'adium comme de bauxite etc
vous aurez ce qu'on appelle un pic c'est
obligatoire c'est pas optionnelle c'est
pas quelque chose qui tient du
malthusianisme c'est pas je ne sais pas
quoi
c'est juste un théorème de maths
appliquées à quelque chose qui est non
renouvelable
alors si le minerai de cuivre est le
fruit d'une transmutation à large
échelle qui apparaissent qui est y avait
lieu dans les entrailles de la terre je
vous tiendrais pas ce discours mais en
l'occurrence pour toutes les ressources
qui ne se renouvelle pas dans les
entrailles de la terre
vous auriez un pic pour les pétroliers
de sa bien puisque en ce qui concerne un
gisement données vous avez toujours un
pic le gisement il produit pas de ce que
ce quand il n'a pas été découverts puis
vous le mettez en production puis il se
met à produire de plus en plus passe par
un maximum puis ça décline et vous avez
à la fin un gisement qui est plié ça
veut également pour un champ un champ
est un ensemble depuis
donc si vous somme est un ensemble de
courbes avec pitch vous retrouver de
nouveau avec une courbe avec pique ça
vaut pour un gros champ cantarelle au
mexique a été je crois le 10e plus gros
change avaient découvert au monde
d'accord
eh bien cantarell la production du
mexique on la verra tout à l'heure a été
divisé quasiment par deux
depuis que le champ a passé son pic en
10 ou 15 ans est allé assez vite
vous avez ici la production de pétrole
conventionnel aux états unis qui a piqué
en 1970 donc c'est hors pétrole de
roche-mère ici vous avez un chameau à la
place du trône d'ailleurs c'est le cas
des etats-unis de la grande-bretagne
pardon où vous voyez un double pic
mais ce qui ne fait pas objection à
montheron de tout à l'heure et voulait
la production d'argent également
et vous voyez très bien ici mon
processus à vous de pâques dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure vous voyez que
les champs qui produisent le plus c'est
à dire les plus gros sont ceux que vous
voyez au début de l'histoire et à la fin
vous avez un croissant c'est à dire
plein de petites feuilles séparés par
plein de petit interstice d'accord un
millefeuille vous voyez que on a arrêté
de découvrir des gros machin alors
encore un truc un peu significatif mais
si on arrêtait de découvrir des gros
machin vous voulez très bien les fièvres
de pâques là dessus là vous avez le
profil de production de puits de pétrole
de roche-mère aux états unis celui-là
est dans le plus grand bassin
actuellement en exploitation aux états
unis qui s'appelle le permien alors le
permien c'est aussi une ère géologique
et on appelle ce bassin le permien parce
que c'est un bassin dans lequel la roche
sédimentaire s'est formée au permien
c'est de là que vient l'essentiel de la
production de pétrole de roche-mère
actuellement aux etats unis
alors vous voyez que après sa mise en
production le puits
la production du puits augmentent très
très vite et au bout d'eux-mêmes pas un
envoyé au bout d'un an
vous êtes à moins de la moitié du pic
qui est lui-même survenue quelques mois
après le début de la mise en production
donc ça c'est pour le permien ça c'est
pour un autre bassin qui s'appelle le no
bara et là vous avez des faits que je
vous mentionnais tout à l'heure qui est
que pour avoir une production croissante
faut rajouter des puits en permanence
c'est là et dès que vous arrêtez de
rajouter des puis crac votre production
se met à décliner très vite alors vous
avez une queue de production qui va
durer très longtemps mais là des niveaux
qui sont beaucoup plus bas que le niveau
auquel vous avez démarré
votre votre puis il ya un certain nombre
de pays qui ont passé leur pic
voilà le mexique comme je le disais tout
à l'heure qui a passé son pic voici
maintenant une décennie ici et depuis ça
a baissé de 40%
ici vous avez l'argentine qui a passé
son pic il ya une petite vingtaine
d'années et depuis ça a baissé également
de manière significative du fait de ce
fait l'argentine était importatrices de
pétrole est devenue exportatrice de
pétrole et de nouveaux importatrices de
pétrole
vous allez ici l'egypte pareil qui a
passé son pic depuis longtemps et depuis
ça a baissé alors pareil là vous avez la
production de l'egypte là vous avez la
consommation de l'egypte au moment où
l'egypte était dans cette phase là elle
a subventionné ces carburants star
qu'elle a dit aux égyptiens va ya plein
de pétrole qui sort de nos puis là on va
vous donner de pétrole pour vraiment pas
cher d'accord dont je vais subventionner
le carburant
et puis arriva le moment où la
production devient inférieure à la
consommation et à ce moment est-ce que
vous pensez que la subvention aux
carburants s'arrête la réponse est non
et donc à ce moment mais ce le drame de
l'egypte il ya d'autres pays qui ont
connu la même histoire
vous vous mettez à subventionner les
importations donc vous avez un phénomène
de déstabilisation de la demande de
pétrole sur le marché mondial
et pour revenir à la question tout à
l'heure qui est pourquoi les prix aussi
là vous avez un pays qui participent à
la non correction par les prix de marché
de l' insuffisance d'offres parce que
comme c'est un pays où la différence
entre prix de marché et un prix fixé à
la pompe est payé par l'état
en fait quand les prix s'envolent c'est
mauvais pour les finances de l'état
mais ça ne change pas grand chose au
comptant comportement du consommateur
ici vous avez dans votre cas de figure
exactement identiques qui est
l'indonésie donc l'indonésie a été
historiquement un des premiers pays
producteurs de pétrole
et soit dit en passant l'indonésie
explique pour ceux d'entre vous qui ne
le savaient pas l'attaqué de pearl
harbor savez entendu parler de l'attaqué
de pearl harbor
donc si vous êtes comme moi mais à 30
ans d'intervalle vous est demandée en
cours d'histoire pourquoi donc est ce
que les japonais ont attaqué les
américains à pearl harbor qui s'il
aurait passé par la tête
pourquoi ils sont allés faire un truc
comme ça les américains les ont gardées
pas il leur demande est rien et pourquoi
et bien la réponse sénat donne ici alors
petite remise en contexte
avant guerre en trente neuf les
etats-unis contrôlent 70% de la
production mondiale de pétrole qu'il
faut pas se demander d'où est venue la
puissance américaine
elle est venue de là 70 % de la
production mondiale de pétrole le japon
dépend notamment des approvisionnements
américain et puis au moment où démarre
la guerre il ya les américains qui se
dit ou là on va quand même être un peu
plus regardants sur la façon dont on
donne du pétrole au japonais est alors à
ce moment les japonais se sont dit on va
faire à paris on va s'approprier le
pétrole indonésien par la force et la
seule manière d'être sûr qu'on va y
arriver
c'est d'anéantir la flotte du pacifique
des américains et le temps qu'ils se
réveillent sert le temps qu'ils
reconstruisent leur marine de guerre
nous on aura sécuriser la route du
pétrole vers l'indonésie on sera
invincible
c'était ça le pari des japonais c'est
tellement bien documentés dans un
bouquin qui s'appelle or noir dans mes
collaborateurs matthieu auzanneau que je
recommande qui fait 600 pages dont vous
avez quoi vaincre quelques insomnies au
revoir et en dessous la grande histoire
du pétrole c'est un remarquable je vous
le conseille en lecture l'indonésie de
mars démarre le xxème siècle comme pays
producteurs de pétrole du coup pareil
subventionne des carburants du coup la
consommation augmente et puis là ils
deviennent importateurs et deviennent
ils doivent subventionner leurs
importations parce que l'indonésie a
passé son pic depuis maintenant
plusieurs décennies enfin le pic même
secondaires et ils ont une production
qui a été divisé par deux et à une
époque le pétrole le ramenait 30 % de
leur pib alors que maintenant ça leur
coûte
5 % en gros de leur pib donc ils ont
fait il ya eu un énorme effet de
balancier dans ce pays où d'énormes
source de recettes à l'exportation
parce que les carburants étaient
subventionnés c'est devenu un gros poste
de déficit ici vous allez le venezuela
alors vous voyez le venezuela a passé
son pic il ya très longtemps donc ils
ont découvert une très grosse baignoire
qui aura un tout petit robinet est donc
la question c'est est-ce que le tout
petit robinet va permettre de faire
remonter sa au dessus pour complètement
suivant ici vous avez l'afrique alors
l'afrique au sens large a passé son pic
en 2009 et depuis a perdu 20 % de son ca
production alors retenez bien ça parce
que l'afrique
c'est un des endroits où l'europe se
fournit l'algérie le nigeria l'angola et
c sont des fournisseurs de pétrole
important de l'europe la mer du nord a
passé son pic en 2000 2e fournisseur
historique important de l'europe
troisième fournisseur important de
l'europe c'est la russie et le ministre
russe de l'énergie a dit donc ça vaut ce
que ça vaut
je vous le donne pas du tout comme une
vérité d'évangile dans la presse il ya
quelques mois
la russie devrait passer son pic de
production dans les années qui viennent
voilà il a réussi ses 30% des
importations européennes
les etats unis ils avaient passé leur
pic sur le conventionnel en soixante dix
ils ont toujours passé du reste en 1970
sur conventionnelle et il ya eu depuis
les faits chez laurie là que vous voyez
très bien sûr ce sursaut graphique et ça
se prolonge même aujourd'hui donc ça
c'est un truc annuelle 1 qui s'arrête en
2017 et ça serait jusqu'en janvier 2019
alors tout le monde surveille en ce
moment ce truc là comme le lait sur le
feu
parce que vous avez une baisse
transitoire actuellement de la province
transitoire une baisse actuellement de
la production de pétrole dans le permis
a1 qui comme je le disais fait
l'essentiel du shale oil aux états unis
et alors tout le monde se dit est-ce que
c'est le début de la fin pour les
producteurs de chez loïc parce que
surendettement parce que ceci parce que
cela en particulier parce que les
actionnaires soient en train de dire à
you want my money back et donc du coup
les foreurs voir et et de forêts en
disant je vais vivre sur le pétrole qui
est déjà produit du coup la production
va baisser et du coup la production
mondiale va faire une tuque ou bien
faudra donc j'en regarde en ce moment de
manière très très scrupuleuse ce qui se
passe aux etats-unis jusqu'à maintenant
et je voulais d'iodé but secours j'ai
compté le pétrole parfois en barils
et je les compte et en barils tout
simplement parce que c'était ce cas des
gens avaient sous la main quand ils ont
commencé à exploiter le pétrole aux
états unis
sauf que le baril n'est pas une unité
d'énergie sont d'accord là dessus c'est
une unité de volume et un petit calcul
vous montre que la quantité d'énergie
contenue dans un baril a tendance à
diminuer au cours du temps alors on le
montre d'une autre manière c'est combien
de barils de pétrole il fait pour faire
une tête de pétrole eh bien vous voyez
que cette quantité a tendance à
légèrement augmenter
et c'est notamment le contrecoup du fait
qu'on m'ait avec le pétrole des produits
plus légers que le pétrole qui avait une
identique pèse moins lourd mais ont
aussi à volume identique un plot tenue
énergétique qui est plus faible
donc quand on compte la production de
pétrole en barils on ne dit pas combien
d'énergie ça ramène pour faire
fonctionner l'exosquelette mondiale en
fait ce qu'on compte est un peu
supérieure avec le temps de plus en plus
supérieurs à ceux qui alimentent
l'exosquelette mondiale un peu
supérieure alors on parlait des états
unis voilà les états unis ici vous avez
la production américaine de pétrole et
la consommation américaine de pétrole
voiliers qui a encore un peu de marge
avant que la production américaine
rattrape la consommation alors c'est
rigolo parce que quand on était là j'ai
entendre j'ai vu un article dans les
échos qui disait en 2020 les états unis
seront autosuffisant bon j'attends
alors on peut passer de exportateurs
importateurs comme l'indonésie sur autre
chose que le pétrole si vous avez le cas
de la grande-bretagne alors la
grande-bretagne qui a été le pays qui
historiquement a connu le maximum absolu
toutes catégories confondues de
production de charbon par personne dans
des bus aux alentours de 1900 il avait
la production de charbon parts est la
plus élevée qui ait jamais eu dans
l'histoire près au dessus des chinois
aujourd'hui mais leurs mines s'étant
épuisés ils sont mis à apporter le
charbon le gaz était importé jusqu'à la
mise en production de la mer du nord
ouest les importations baissent
à un moment il se met à exporter et puis
il se remet tant apporté
et en ce qui concerne le pétrole c'est
pareil donc ici vous avez en creux le
double pic de la mer du nord donc ils
exportaient beaucoup il exporte le il va
exporte beaucoup pistes sont bien
portées alors maintenant la question
c'est en ce qui concerne le monde dans
son ensemble qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
alors sur le monde a son ensemble je
vous ai vus tout je voulais montrer tout
à l'heure que les découvertes de pétrole
conventionnel qui constitue encore
aujourd'hui le gros de la production de
pétrole dans le monde à plus de 75 % y
compris en incluant les liquides de gaz
c'est du pétrole conventionnel
ce que vous dit ce graphique c'est que
quand vous commencez à avoir découvert
et exploité une grande partie des
gisements qui sont contenus dans une
zone
vous avez la matérialisation d'un
décalage constant entre le moment où
vous découvrez et le moment où vous
sortez de terre ce que vous avez sur ce
graphique c'est les années qui séparent
une fraction données de ce qui va sortir
comme pétrole qui a été découvert et le
moment où ce pétrole est effectivement
extrait donc la totalité de ce qu'il a
découvert ces les réserves ultimes et je
dis je regarde le décalage en année
entre g entre le moment où je découvre
30% des réserves ultimes et le moment où
j'ai extrait 30% des réserves ultimes et
bien vous voyez que quand vous êtes au
tout début que vous avez découvert
extrait qu'une petite partie des
réserves ultimes c'est un truc qui
varient mais avec le temps ça finit par
se stabiliser à une valeur qui
raisonnablement constante et à ce moment
vous dit
et bien sûr ce bassin là c'est à peu
près cette valeur-là qui va séparer le
maximum de découverte du maximum de
production c'est comme ça que vous date
et le pic de façon anticipative sur les
gisements conventionnels
alors ça marche très bien pour les états
unis et c'est grâce à ça que marion qui
gilberte au début des années 50 dit le
pic de production aux états unis ça sera
1970 et s'est pas trompé à l'année près
il a eu raison
ça marche très bien pour la france alors
ici en l'occurrence on a pas on a décalé
dans le temps pour montrer la
superposition de deux cycles de
découverte et de cycle là c'était sept
ans en france
et puis pour le monde dans son ensemble
eh bien vous avez le maximum des
découvertes qui est dans les années 60
et donc le maximum de production sera
décalée de quelque chose qui va
ressembler à en gros 50 ans donc je
quand je dis 50
en fait ça pourrait être un peu plus
long parce que vous allez avoir un peu
plus de dégâts et c est donc ce que
disent la majeure partie des
spécialistes et qu'on va vivre une
période en plateau ou du lait pendant
une période mal définis 5 ans 10 ans 15
ans qui a probablement commencé dans les
années 2000 qui va se prolonger jusque
on sait pas qu'en 2030
peut-être après peut-être avant ça va
dépendre aussi de ce qu'on fait sur le
climat et qui va être une période de
fortes oscillations des prix à cause du
processus que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
et puis derrière il y aura un déclin
parce que mon théorème assimilés roll
s'appliquera de toute façon donc pas que
pense l'automobiliste français et
quoique pense automobilistes américains
et quoique pense automobilistes chinois
et quoique pense l'automobiliste sud
africains de toutes façons ça déclinera
puis il faudra vivre avec et si on veut
respecter les engagements sur le climat
dont on va parler dans les deux cours
qui suivront il faut en plus que ça
décline plus vite que ce que la géologie
nous impose mais ce que je suis en train
de vous expliquer là c'est qu'il ya
toute façon une voiture balai qui est
que même si on veut pas de toute façon
il ya un moment où on a moins quand même
ces deux là le charme du monde fini tout
cas avoir indéfiniment plus en plus dans
cette affaire là il ya une confusion
très importante qui a lieu en permanence
qui consiste à mélanger des durées et
des volumes
vous avez aussi peut-être pour un
certain nombre de vous lu ou entendu il
nous reste trente ans de pétrole alors
quand on dit ça on fait quelque chose
qui est il légitime
on compte un volume 1 d'énergie
résiduelles en année moi je sais compter
du temps en année mais comptez un volume
d'énergie résiduelles en année c'est
plus compliqué alors à fait ce que les
gens sous-entendent quand ils disent ça
c'est que si vous multipliez la
consommation de là des fois une durée
vous obtenez le volume d'énergie qui
restent donc en fait ils parlent d'une
intégrale alors il ya une première
confusion dans cette histoire c'est que
l'intégrale dont il parle c'est celle là
sauf qu' aucune consommation devra
suivre une courbe de cette nature tiers
sauf à avoir une peste bubonique géante
qui intervient le 1er janvier de la 41e
année qui supprime tous les
consommateurs et donc toute consommation
vous n'avez pas 40 ans de pétrole comme
ça tient que vous avez pas 40 ans à
consommation constante
puis le 1er janvier de la 41e a les
crocs la passe 1 0
n'existe pas donc compter en années
ça peut avoir du sens si vous désignez
l'intégrale mais ça vous donne une
fausse idée de tranquillité parce que à
chaque fois que vous entendez il y en a
pour 40 ans de pétrole moi j'entends je
suis tranquille pour 40 ans c'est
évidemment c'est à 30 ans et en fait
pour être tranquille il faudrait qu'on
ait encore mieux que ça il faudrait
qu'on ait 40 ans croissant puisque ce
qui nous assure la tranquillité c'est la
croissance donc une production
croissante
donc en fait c'est plutôt tranquille
pour 32 ans en fait la bonne manière de
comprendre ça ces sept combats
c'est à dire que vous pouvez très bien
avoir 40 ans de pétrole au sens de
l'intégrale vos quarante fois la
consommation de l'année et pour autant
vous êtes demain matin en production
déclinante
or ce qu'il va faire mal à l'économie je
vais vous le montrer dans pas longtemps
c'est pas le fait que l'intégrale est
encore 40 ans ou 60 ou 80 ou 253 c'est
le fait que cette ressource qui est la
ressource indispensable aux échanges
donc à l'économie telle qu'elle est
configuré aujourd'hui viennent pas
manquer demain au sens où demain j'en ai
3 % de moins c'est ça qui est important
le fait qu' il m'en reste entre
guillemets pour 40 fois le fait que le
volume de ma baignoire soit 40 fois ce
qui est sortie du robinet l'année
dernière ça ne donne pas le débit futur
d'accord ça ne me donne pas le débit
futur
quelque chose qui est plus intéressant à
regarder ont semble-t-il c'est la façon
dont le débit du robinet l'avarié sur
les 150 dernières années donc ici vous
avez une courbe qui vous donne une mine
qui sentent sur dix ans et déjà c'est
assez heurtée au début qui vous donne la
variation de la production mondiale de
pétrole
donc ce que vous voyez c'est qu'il ya un
siècle et demi avec des moyens
techniques somme toute très rudimentaire
j'avais une production mondiale de
pétrole qui augmentent est tous les ans
de 15% en gros et puis vous voyez que
quelques décennies plus tard avec des
moyens techniques qui sont déjà beaucoup
plus sophistiqué en fait je ne sais pas
faire mieux que + 10 % par an ce qui est
déjà énorme
là vous voyez qu au moment des chocs
pétroliers en fait on est passé de 10 %
par an a beaucoup moins que 10 pour cent
ans on sait pas il faut pétroliers c'est
là les chocs pétroliers avec le des
moyens encore plus sophistiquée après je
suis descendu plus tôt à 5 et la part
dont vous voyez les chocs pétroliers et
après les chocs pétroliers ça descend
longtemps à 0 puis à pas grand chose
malgré les hydrocarbures de roche-mère
qui sont des techniques encore plus
sophistiquée alors pour la petite
histoire la première exploitation
d'hydrocarbures de roche-mère a eu lieu
en 1824 ou 26 je ne sais jamais l'autre
c'est la découverte de l'effet de serre
par foyer donc je confondais de en
permanence aux états unis dans une
petite ville de l'est américain qui
s'appelle fredonia donc le où on avait
exploité du shale gas pour de
l'éclairage municipal
donc les les hydrocarbures de roche-mère
c'est connu depuis deux siècles
il faut pas croire que c'est un truc
qu'on a découvert très récemment ce
qu'on a découvert très récemment c'est
une technique qui permet de les extraire
du sol de façon à peu près intéressante
mais c'est ça qu'on a découvert
récemment c'est pas la ressource elle
même voilà voilà donc que si vous vous
dites ce qui compte c'est la concavité
de la courbe
c'est à dire la dérivée seconde bas on
n'arrive pas très loin du moment où la
dérive et doit être annulée et donc on
arrive au pic on ne voit pas on est très
loin
ici vous avez une décomposition mais qui
malheureusement s'arrête en 2013 dans
laquelle on a décomposé le le pétrole
conventionnel est ici les condensats ici
les liquides de gaz est ici les extra
lourd et vous verrez que si je prends le
vrai pétrole entre guillemets et bien
depuis le milieu des années 2000
ça s'est arrêté de croître et en fait ce
qu'ils croient c'est les condensats et
les liquides de gaz c'est à dire deux
produits qui sortent avec le gaz avec le
gaz ici vous avez une projection qui a
été fait il ya une dizaine d'années sur
la production mondiale de liquide alors
vous voyez le pétrole conventionnel au
sens des gisements conventionnels
c'est quelque chose qui va jusqu'aux
eaux claires là si vous y rajoutez le
les sables bitumineux aller ça monte
jusqu'au bleu fut monsieur les canadiens
à la salle monte jusqu'au bleu foncé et
et vous voyez que
le maximum est donc aux alentours des
années 2020 est ici vous avez un saint
mais ça va beaucoup dépendre de ce terme
là qui sont les liquides de gaz et les
et le shale oil
mais ça ne va pas empêcher à un moment
le déclin de l'ensemble à cause du
déclin du conventionnel ça va
probablement plus ralentir le déclin que
empêchait le déclin est plein de gens
que je connais disent depuis longtemps
c'est 2020 plus ou moins cinq ans et
plus ou moins 5 millions de barils jour
dans un sens ou dans l'autre
j'y reviendrai la question du prix après
alors ici je vous cite des tâches ans
avait de la chance de la première promo
aka droit à ça ça fait dix ans que je
raconte la même chose sur le fait que le
pic devrait pas être très loin dans le
rapport world energy outlook de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie qui est
sorti en décembre dernier
vous trouvez là c'est pareil ça n'a pas
fait les gros titres de la presse
cette phrase que je vous invite à
méditer donc l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie vous dis en 2018 ça fait dix
ans comme aurait dit coluche ils
auraient pu s'en rendre compte avant ça
fait dix ans que la production de
pétrole conventionnel dans le monde est
passé par son maximum et depuis elle est
en déclin donc l' agence internationale
de l'énergie vous dit en ce qui concerne
la partie qui n'est pas le che l'oeil et
la partie qui n'est pas des sables
bitumineux
nous avons un déclin qui a démarré il ya
dix ans dans le même rapport
l' agence internationale de l'énergie
vous dise à un qu'il ya un risque
d'offre 1,2 de réduction de l'offre
supply crunch et qu' il n'y a pas ce
qu'il faut pour monter l'offre au niveau
de la demande si on ne multiplie pas par
trois la production actuelle de schieren
aux états unis et quand vous vous
tourner vers les projections de celle
aux etats unis les projections les plus
optimistes tablent plutôt sur 1 x 2
avant une stabilisation
qui va durer ce qu'elle va durer donc
apprêtez vous à vivre une époque
intéressante parce que la réponse du
système à cette affaire-là que je vais
vous montrer dans pas longtemps sera en
gros une grosse déstabilisation
économique alors la première chose qu'il
faut avoir à l'esprit c'est que la façon
dont cette déstabilisation arrive n'est
pas contrairement à ce que vous entendez
parfois dans vos cours d'économie vais
je pas être méchant avec les profs
d'économie une augmentation indéfinie du
prix du baril vous savez que vous
apprenez en cours d'économie
s'il y en a moins c'est plus cher et
s'il y en a plus c'est moins cher donc
s'il y en a de moins en moins ça devrait
être la plus en plus cher et si vous en
avez de plus en plus ça devrait être de
moins en moins cher donc si je fais un
graphique dans lequel j'ai la quantité
totale de pétrole utilisé là et là le
prix du baril vous êtes d'accord avec
moi que je devrais avoir des points qui
s'organise le long d'une course qui
ressemble à peu près à ça d'accord si
chaque année je reporte prix et volumes
eh bien mon nuage de points devrait se
balader le long d'un truc qui ressemble
à ça ce que vous voyez ne ressemble
absolument pas à ça la première chose
que vous voyez c'est que la relation
prix volumes en ce qui concerne le
pétrole n'est pas objective d'accord
avec moi si vous voyez une déjection là
dedans on paye le champagne est d'accord
c'est un objectif
alors c'est pas bougé ctif et ça a
évolué même si vous essayez de
simplifier avec deux régimes totalement
inélastique c'est à dire que la valeur
d'un des paramètres ne dépend absolument
pas de la valeur de l'autre et qui sont
totalement orthogonaux là on en vient à
la question de tout à l'heure c'est le
pet
donc vous avez une très très longue
période pendant laquelle le prix du
baril est totalement indépendant du
volume est totalement stable
les chocs pétroliers c'est un régime
exactement inverse où vous avez un
volume à peu près constant qu'il ya à
peu près constant et un prix totalement
erratique
puis il arrive de nouveau une période où
vous avez un prix à peu près constant et
un volume qui varient significativement
et de nouveau
un épisode dans lequel vous avez un
volume qui varie peu parce que je vous
rappelle que l'essentiel de la crème en
là ce n'est pas du pétrole c'est plutôt
de liquides de gaz qui ne sont pas
cotées évidemment sur le marché du brent
donc avec un prix qui fait n'importe
quoi alors ce que je suis en train de
vous dire là c'est que la raréfaction du
pétrole
et c'est également aussi à cause du
phénomène d'oscillation dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure ne se matérialisera pas
par une envolée indéfinie des prix c'est
pas ça qui va se passer ça ne s'est pas
passé dans le passé ça ne se passera pas
dans le futur
les deux indicateurs qui vont vous
caractérisez une raréfaction du pétrole
le premier c'est l'augmentation
indéfinie des investissements à
consentir pour extraire appareils
supplémentaires dit autrement c'est la
hausse des investissements nécessaires
pour extraire ou pour faire un puits
supplémentaires pour extraire du pétrole
ça c'est le premier marqueur donc ce
qu'il faut regarder c'est les
investissements j'ai regardé tout à
l'heure c'est pas donc les
investissements croissants je voulais
montrer tout à l'heure ça c'est une
marque un début de raréfaction le
deuxième indicateur que
qu'il faut surveiller en fait c'est le
pardon l'indicateur qu'il faut
surveiller ses des capex et le deuxième
la deuxième manière dont va se
matérialiser une insuffisance de pétrole
j'y viendrai dans pas longtemps
c'est par une contraction d'économies
c'est par une baisse du pib mais c'est
pas par une hausse du prix du baril
alors comme par contre les gens qui font
des projections sur les prix du baril
utilisent des modèles dans lesquels il
ya des élasticités qui n'existe pas dans
la vraie vie
voilà ce que ça donne quand on fait des
projections sur le prix du pétrole vous
avez ici en rouge
ce qu'a vraiment été la variation du
prix du pétrole et tous les spaghettis
horizontaux là c'est des projections qui
figurent dans les rapports de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie sur ce que
sera le prix du pétrole plus tard bon je
ne sais pas vous mais moi si j'ai un
responsable marketing chez moi qui me
fait des projections de cette nature je
pas sûr que je vais garder très
longtemps
année après année on recommence donc
allé voir dans le world energy outlook
de 2018 et vous verrez vous avez encore
je voulais pas me la mets vous avez
encore des projections de prix du
pétrole sur 20 ans évidemment ça vaut
pas un clou ça n'empêche pas quelques
jours n'a quelques journaux dont un
certain journal du soir qui se veut de
référence de recopier le prix du baril
devrait atteindre 80 dollars en 2038
si ça les amuse mais on s'en fout de
toute façon c'est pas ça le sujet
puisque le prix n'a pas beaucoup
d'importance
ce qu'il a de l'importance sept volumes
1 et ici vous avez une corrélation alors
au début je n'avais que la corrélation
j'avais pas compris le rapport de cause
à effet le rapport de cause à effet gelé
compris quand j'ai compris ce que je
vous ai expliqué au premier cours c'est
à dire que l'énergie c'est ce qui
alimente les machines et les machines
c'est ce qui fait la production et en
particulier le pétrole qui permet les
échanges entre machines
c'est à dire que le pétrole c'est ce qui
permet que le camion transporte le
podium ourthe qui a été fait dans une
usine de pots de yaourt jusque dans les
usines de danone où on va le remplir
avec du yaourt puis de nouveau jusque
dans le supermarché où vous allez
l'acheter en y allant soit dit en
passant avec votre voiture une fois sur
deux le pétrole c'est ce qui permet ça
donc c'est le fluide qui permet
l'organisation du système physique
mondiale
production si demain matin j'ai pu de
pétrole j'ai beau avoir de l'électricité
j'ai pas une marchandise qui est livré
dans une usine j'ai pas une matière
première qui est livré dans une usine
j'ai pas un produit qui part d'une usine
les choix dit en passant j'ai pas 80%
des français qui peuvent aller au
travail le matin
donc vous avez un une dépendance de
l'économie mondiale au transport d'eau
qu'au pétrole qui est absolument totale
et qui se matérialise par cette courbe
que vous avez là où vous avez en rouge
la variation annuelle en fait c'est une
moyenne lissée sur trois ans mais la
variation de la quantité de pétrole qui
sort des puits c'est une quantité c'est
pas un prix c'est un nombre de barinas
un nombre de tonnes peu importe donc
c'est la variation est en bleu vous avez
la variation du pib par personne dans le
monde
alors ce que vous voyez c'est que avant
les chocs pétroliers
les deux variations sont semblables en
signe mais pas du tout en valeur
enfin en quantité et ça ça veut dire que
avant les chocs pétroliers
en fait l'économie est moins dépendante
du pétrole que après donc après on a eu
deux processus
1 la mondialisation qui a rallongé les
chaînes logistiques donc rendu plus
dépendants du pétrole de l'efficacité
énergétique qui fait que chaque dollar
utilisent moins de pétrole mais du coup
quand vous détruisez un baril de pétrole
vous détruisez plus de dollars vous
mettez plus de machines à l'arrêt
aujourd'hui en ayant un baril de pétrole
en moins que ça n'était le cas en 1960
parce que les machines sont plus
efficaces donc le revers de la médaille
c'est que du coup elles sont aussi plus
dépendantes
est ce que vous voyez également de
manière très intéressante sur ce
graphique c'est que la variation du
pétrole se situe globalement légèrement
en avance de phase par rapport à la
variation du pib
donc c'est un valide l'idée qui est
qu'il y aura une croissance qui vient de
mars et que du coup on consomme du
pétrole parce qu'on en a les moyens
en fait la façon dont ça se passe
confère le premier cours c'est comme
vous avez les moyens de mettre les
machines en action du coup ça produit et
vous avez du pib c'est bien en ce sens
là quelque chose se passe
alors le phénomène d'asservissement qui
est jeu j'ai un peu plus d'argent le
pétrole est un peu moins cher du coup
j'en achète un peu plus il ne pilote pas
la variation du pib par contre il pilote
conciliation des prix dont je parlais
tout à l'heure mais retenez bien ce
graphique
parce que ce graphique il vous dit
quelque chose de très simple il vous dit
que le jour où le shale oil se casse la
gueule aux états unis la courbe rouge
passant négatif et du coup la courbe
bleue passant négatif et du coup votre
avenir
c'est que vous demanderez à votre
employeur de vous payer un peu moins
chaque année c'est ça une récession
donc ce que je tout ce que je voudrais
raconter pendant ce court sur le pétrole
encore aujourd'hui ou parle énormément d
autres énergies mais vous avez vu au
premier cours que c'était toujours pas
grand chose
ce que je vous ai raconté aujourd'hui en
ce qui concerne le pétrole
retenez le bien pas juste pour faire
plaisir quand il fera très plaisir mais
retenez le bien parce que c'est quelque
chose qui va jouer un rôle central dans
le monde dans lequel vous allez vivre
pour le temps qu'il va vous restez à
vivre que j'espère très long à vos
souhaits alors maintenant regardons la
zone ocde
vous avez ici l'évolution de la quantité
d'énergie utilisée par énergie dans la
zone ocde et vous remarquerez que comme
pour la france que je voulais monter
tout à l'heure
choc pétrolier ça s'arrête de monter ça
reste globalement stable jusqu'en 2006
et là ça commence à décliner et la
consommation de pétrole de la zone ocde
aujourd'hui est inférieure à ce qu'elle
était en 2006 alors 2006 je vous
rappelle que ces deux ans avant la crise
économique de 2008
enfin vous la crise financière de 2009 3
en avant et deux ans avant la faillite
de lehman brothers
et quand vous regardez bien
l'enchaînement chronologique de ce qui
s'est passé pendant ces années là vous
avez d'abord ralentissement énergétique
puis ralentissement de la production
le pib décélère avant la crise
financière et après cela la barre ou
massart attaque une montagne de dettes
qu'on avait commencé à créer au moment
du premier choc pétrolier c'est ce que
je vous ai expliqué la dernière fois
pour compenser une augmentation de la
production qui ne savait déjà plus
suivre l'augmentation de la
redistribution
en europe même motif même punition
vous voyez ici le pic de la mer du nord
sas et les importations et bien le début
donc deux ans avant le pic de production
du conventionnel la production mondiale
s'arrêtent quasiment de croître et à ce
moment les importations en europe
commence à décroître et l'europe entre
en crise elle aussi le pétrole
aujourd'hui d'où est ce qu il vient et
bien c'est ce que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure
voyez c'est intéressant de savoir ce que
raconte le ministre russe de l'énergie
ça fait quand même un gros paquet du
pétrole 40 chez nous
le moyen-orient c'est pas énorme ça
c'est le nigeria l'angola
ça c'est la mer du nord qui est en
contraction voilà et donc vous avez
et là vous avez l'afrique du nord s'est
notamment l'algérie alors l'algérie et
post pic en ce qui concerne son pétrole
la mer du nord et post pique ça se voit
très bien ici vous avez l'afrique
subsaharienne qui est post pique ça
commence à faire beaucoup quoi rsa
réussi donc c'est pas complètement sûr
que vous ayez terminer vos études ici au
plus tard avant qu'il se passe des
choses assez étonnante de ceux de ce
côté là je le répète c'est pas le prix
l'indicateur dominant donc on avait
commencé le premier cours par ça je vous
le redis l'importation de pétrole en
france et quelques pour cent du pib mais
100% du pib en dépendent
100% même mon producteur super bio sympa
avec les coccinelles et c'est chez qui
je vais acheter des patates il dépend du
pétrole
d'accord il n'ya pas son camion qui va
au marché il n'y a pas de patates et
comme il est à dourdan c'est un peu loin
pour y aller le matin avant de venir au
boulot donc vous êtes donc vous avez une
dépendance totale
je dis bien totale aujourd'hui de
l'économie au moyen de transport et donc
c'est pas parce que ça nous coûte 3 % du
pib que c'est pas important ce que vous
voyez ici c'est la variation de
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne sur durée très longue
un siècle et demi et en rouge vous avez
la valeur moyenne par grandes périodes
avant le choc pétrolier après les chocs
pétroliers
ben vous voyez qu après les chocs
pétroliers on a vraiment descendu une
marche d'escalier
en ce qui concerne la variation de cet
approvisionnement énergétique
donc ça a vraiment marqué une rupture
dans le dans le monde
alors moi je vais aller plus vite pour
le reste le gaz même motif même punition
le gaz se découvre après il s'extrait et
vous avez aussi un décalage dans le
temps qui fait que etc et des
évaluations patates et chiffons c'est
exactement la même chose
et quand on demande aux gens
qu'est-ce que quand est ce que pourrait
être le pic de production du gaz vont
ils vous disent bourreau 2030-2040 corps
donc on est dans des eaux qui sont
voisines
en ce qui concerne l'europe aujourd'hui
encore la moitié de notre gaz vient de
la mer du nord la mer du nord a passé
son pic en 2005 et regarder la quantité
de gaz consommé par les européens qui
étaient en augmentation constante
jusqu'au pic de la mer du nord se met à
décliner depuis
alors vous allez me dire c'est pas un
problème y en a plus chez nous il ya
encore chez les russes faisant venir le
gaz des russes sauf que il faut dix ans
pour faire un gazoduc nord stream 1
et ça c'est dans un cas où ça se passe
entre guillemets bien parce que les
allemands et les russes sont quand même
pas très loin via la baltique et les
états intermédiaires en gros il ya moyen
de les contrôler c'est pas toujours
aussi simple et de toute façon encore
une fois c'est dire donc si l'on est là
dedans vous avez la norvège qui n'a pas
passé son pic on va le voir au prochain
graphique mais quand elle va passer son
pic se respecte a décliné beaucoup plus
vite donc le gaz des russes d'abord en
plus les rues sont les boycotts à cause
des misères qui font h et à qui donc si
ils mettent des nouveaux gisements en
production qui sont à équidistance des
chinois et des européens à votre avis
ils vont bande de gaza qui s'est pas
complètement sûr qu'ils nous les vendent
à dos donc comptait pas trop sur les
russes pour les importations gaz ou est
ce qu'on peut avoir du gaz ailleurs on
peut avoir du gaz liquéfié faut
construire les trains de liquéfaction
c'est très long et le gaz liquéfié rla
pour le coup comme le bateau se baladent
partout on est en concurrence avec les
pays qui le payent le plus cher qui paye
le plus cher dans le monde le gaz
liquéfié
les asiatiques au sens large et les
japonais en particulier
donc si je suis qatari et que je fais un
train de liquéfaction de gaz
j'ai plutôt intérêt à m'entendre avec
les japonais cave entendre avec les
européens puisque japonais peu à peu
près deux fois plus cher donc tout ça
pour dire que c'est pas complètement sûr
qu'on est plein de gaz en europe et
alors indépendamment de tout problème de
climat tous les gens qui se disent on va
remplacer n'importe quoi le charbon le
nucléaire par du gaz fletcher condé gaz
j'ai jamais vu aujourd'hui à scénario
électrique de remplacement du charbon et
ou du nucléaire par du gaz encore une
fois indépendamment de toutes
considérations carbone couplé à la
disponibilité possible en gaz en europe
dans ce contexte là mais c'est quand
même une question qu'il faut se poser
vous allez dire deuxième chose il n'ya
qu'à faire du chien de gaz chez nous
qu'on ferait pas du ch et le gaz chez
nous alors la raison pour laquelle on
fait pas du shale gas chez nous il y en
a plusieurs
vous savez peut-être et sinon je vais
vous apprendre quelque chose aux états
unis l'état n'est pas propriétaire du
sous sol
dans tous les autres pays du monde soit
parce que c'est pas des démocraties où
quelqu'un l'état est propriétaire de
tout soi-même on est dans des
démocraties
mais il ya un partage entre ce qui est
dans le bien public phase qui est dans
la collectivité et ce qui est chez vous
l'état est propriétaire du sous sol donc
si chez vous dans le jardin votre grand
mère vous découvrez de l'or à 200 mètres
de profondeur mauvaise nouvelle il est
pas ça c'est ballot hein donc voulait
pas aller chercher parce que sinon
ensuite vous êtes emmerder avec la mine
d'or c'est pas terrible et vous en avez
pas les bénéfices est exproprié dont
vous avez aucun intérêt à aller chercher
dans le fond de votre jardin s'il ya de
leur opa de 100 mètres de profondeur aux
etats unis le sous sol sans limitation
de profondeur appartient au propriétaire
du sol du coup pas de concessions
minières a demandé à l'état alors quand
en france le régime est très simple on
trouve de l'or à 200 m d'abord il faut
que quelqu'un vienne chercher l'or pour
vous qu'est ce que vous avez fait quand
même passé avec votre lampe de poche
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on
accorde un permis d'exploration puis si
le personnes qui exploitent en retrouve
quelque chose il faut qu'on leur accorde
un permis d'exploitation et comme elle
va devoir vous passer sur le corps
puisque c'est pas chez vous à 200 mètres
de profondeur en gros vous êtes
expropriés donc une autorisation
d'exploitation en france égale une
expropriation
sinon
vous avez évidemment allez vous battre
devant les tribunaux parce que quand
même le jardin votre grand-mère une
valeur sentimentale et donc le temps on
arrive au bout et aux états unis
non votre grand mère dit aux foreurs du
coin bien de faire un trou dans mon
jardin et si tu trouves du pétrole on se
partage le résultat c'est comme ça que
ça marche
l'état n'a absolument pas son mot à dire
c'est la raison pour laquelle les états
unis c'est le pays plus trouver du monde
vous avez aujourd'hui 1,7 million de
puits de pétrole et de gaz en activité
aux états unis d'une 7 millions ils font
100 mille trous par an comme gainsbourg
en jeu des trous enfin la géologie s'y
prête donc ils sont fils ont vraiment
une roche mère avec du gaz dedans et
dernier point quand vous faites un trou
quelque part dans l'essentiel des états
unis tout ce que vous emmerdez c'est des
chiens de prairie ou des vaches mères
des personnes c'est un pays dont peuples
et les états unis vous avez démence fin
je veux dire dans toute l'immensité du
texas etc
les personnes du coup vous pouvez faire
des pistes et puis c'est tout plat donc
vous pouvez faire des pistes pour
acheminer des camions pour évacuer le
pétrole que vous avez trouvé
alors maintenant on va reprendre le cas
de figure en france 1 puis eyal une
expropriation
c'est densément peuplées si vous trouvez
du pétrole vous devez faire une piste
pour évacuer avec des camions le pétrole
que vous avez trouvez vous avez
éventuellement vous avez évidemment 452
riverains que vous aller emmerder en
faisant ça si vous n'avez pas de
riverains si vous êtes en zone
montagneuse
donc ça va vous coûter très cher de
faire les pistes etc bon bref
donc les gens qui pensent que le ch
elias va être un eldorado dans les pays
européens
à mon avis je parle toutes mes économies
contre eux que ça ne sera jamais le cas
peut-être qu'on peut en faire sortir si
on en fait sortir lettre de grandeur de
ce qui sort c'est ça donc la probabilité
que ce soit quelque chose qui va changer
fondamentalement les ordres de grandeur
en europe est de mon point de vue à peu
près nulles oui
il sent que c'est dit m ne pas vous dire
de bêtises médecin de m il est sûr
jusqu'à les racines d'un chêne ça va
plus profond quand même si c'est pas
beaucoup en tout cas on pourrait lancer
les paris mais je suis pas sur mais
disent se passer de septembre là je vous
parlais du gaz
donc voilà la production de gaz par pays
dans la mer du nord à l'heure du gaz
dans la mer si bien sûr sous la mer oui
comme le pétrole offshore la mer du nord
s'est essentiellement de l'offshore
parce que en france n'est pas sous les
mers voilà vous en guyane par exemple
vous avez si vous lisez un peu la presse
vous avez un total à explorer pour
trouver du pétrole à trouver du pétrole
il ya eu toute une controverse dans
laquelle l'eau un peu râler sur
l'exploitation ou non de ce pétrole au
large de la guyane
donc bien sûr en cherchant la mère aussi
alors après pour qu'on trouve du pétrole
et du gaz je le répète il faut que vous
soyez dans une zone sédimentaire
si vous êtes dans une zone volcanique
par exemple ça marche très bien d'accord
au la martinique et la guyane sauf
heures et la guadeloupe sauf erreur de
ma part c'est volcanique donc la
probabilité que vous trouviez beaucoup
de pétrole d'abord n'est pas très élevé
voilà donc c'est ça dépend de ce que
vous avez comme possession d'outre-mer
vous avez dû vous avez pas mal de
pétrole dans le gaz dans le golfe du
gabon golf eux qui est à l'ouest de
l'afrique de l'ouest est là où il y
avait des explorations offshore donc
vous faites des plates formes
d'exploitation et comme je le disais
tout à l'heure comme vous n'avez pas de
gazoducs qui flottent à la surface de la
mer
les exploitations de gaz offshore ou
produisent nécessairement du gaz
liquéfié que vous exploitez que vous
extrayez pardon par par méthaniers et la
bébête coûte 10 milliards pièce pas le
méthanier mais la plateforme
donc voilà la production de la mer du
nord vous voyez que le seul pays qui n'a
pas passé son pic c'est la norvège et le
pic de la norvège est attendu pour 2020
plus ou moins à quelque chose ici vous
avez une histoire marrante que je vous
aurais raconter si on avait le temps sur
la fin de l'extraction du gaz aux pays
bas la décompression je vais vous le
dire en 15 secondes quand même la
décompression des champs de gaz
souterrain qui eux sont à terre dans les
pays bas créer des micro fractures et
des micros tremblement de terre en
quantité croissante et donc le
gouvernement hollandais a décidé
délibérément de diviser par dix
l'extraction de gaz de ses champs pour
éviter des affaissements en quantité
croissante avec évidemment les riverains
au dessus qui sont pas très contents
voilà donc ici vous avez la production
de gaz de la norvège tels que elle est
stimulée par un certain nombre de gens
après le reste charme
on en parlera la prochaine dans des
énergies renouvelables après le bronze
du charbon alors je vous le dis et je
vous le répète le charbon est une
énergie domestique et le charbon sert
essentiellement à produire de
l'électricité soit dit en passant une
des raisons pour lesquelles la chine
mettant l'accent sur la voiture
électrique c'est pas que chez elle avec
sa production d'électricité au charbon
on gagne énormément sur le co2 ni même
sur les particules fines
encore qu elles sont émises ailleurs
mais c'est que ça a déjà comme avantage
de passer d'un peu trop l'emporter à
charbon domestique donc avant même
d'être un sujet de co2 c'est un sujet de
souveraineté énergétique entre autres
sujets c'est aussi un sujet de renouveau
industriel donc ici vous avez du charbon
et là vous avez les réserves prouvées
donc telle que déclaré de charbon d
dix premiers détenteurs de réserves dans
le monde alors il faut savoir que ces
dix pays possède plus de neuf dixièmes
du charbon dans le monde donc le charbon
et éventuellement bien répartie par
continent il a extrêmement mal réparties
par pays alors comme par ailleurs on le
verra pendant les cours sur le climat le
charbon est l'énergie qui est la plus
émissive de co2 par kilowattheure et que
par ailleurs c'est la ressource fossile
dont les quantités restantes extractible
a entre guillemets n'importe quel prix
est la plus importante
on va dire dès maintenant je le redirai
la prochaine fois que l'avenir
climatique du monde et notamment dans
les mains de ces dix pays là parce que
c'est eux qui décident ou non de façon
souveraine d'utiliser leur charbon chez
eux puisque encore une fois le charbon
est une énergie qui s'utilise chez soi
donc le la quantité de charbon de ces
pays là et l'utilisation qu'ils vont en
faire c'est un des déterminants majeurs
de ce qui va se passer en ce qui
concerne le climat
alors vous voyez que les trois premiers
détenteurs ou de réserve c'est les deux
frères ennemis de toujours là la russie
et les etats unis avec au milieu la
chine et une fois vous devez l'australie
et là vous avez quand même
je vais avoir 70 à 75% du charbon
mondial après vous avez deux types de
charbon en foncé vous allez ce qu'on
appelle leur art cole en anglais ou là
où il en fera site en français ou le
charbon vapeur
plus exactement qui sont des charbons à
haute teneur en carbone et qui sont des
charbons anciens donc scellé charbon qui
sont descendus en général bas sous terre
qui s'exploitent en galeries
souterraines et qui sont allés au bout
de leur processus de pyrolyse donc ils
sont riches en carbone peuvent en
cendres les pauvres en éléments volatils
quand le charbon est jeune c'est l'exact
inverse
il est riche en éléments à combustible
riche en eau et il est près de la
surface et à ce moment ça s'appelle
alors la tourbe c'est vraiment du
charbon très très jeune mais sinon ça
s'appelle du charbon allemand et c'est à
dire ni tu exactement et ce charbon la
lui s'exploite non pas en galerie mais
en mille à ciel ouvert et donc pour ceux
d'entre vous qui ont envie et même ce
pack qui ont pas envie parce que c'est
intéressant à regarder
prenez un coup de google maps et à les
regarder à quoi ressemble vue de
l'espace les mines de lignite allemande
ça vous fait des gros trous quand même
un bon stage un gros truc de 5 km sur 5
km et la mine à ciel ouvert de grands
bars
si ma mémoire est bonne est une des
mines à ciel ouvert qui descend le plus
bas au monde
les quasiment 300 mètres sous le niveau
de la mer et c'est là dedans aussi que
vous avez la plus grosse excavatrice de
charbon au monde un truc qui fait jeu
pourquoi 150 100 100 150 mètres de haut
2 100 mètres de long le cab so lu ment
monstrueux voilà donc le charbon
retenez que ces pays-là qui en ont de
plus et si maintenant je finis cet
exposé en agrégeant charbon pétrole et
gaz
voilà à quoi ressemble les réserves
mondiales donc ce que vous voyez c'est
que dans les réserves mondiales
ce qui domine c'est le charbon
vous voyez que les plus gros détenteurs
de pétrole au monde
alors le venezuela c'est vraiment très
particulier parce que comme je le disais
c'est une grosse baignoire mais avec un
tout petit robinet mais si je prends
l'arabie saoudite l'arabie saoudite est
un vin de jardin à côté du charbon ont
possédé par les américains alors il se
trouve qu'en ce moment on assiste depuis
dix ans à quelque chose de très amusant
aux états unis les états unis sont en
train de diminuer la quantité de charbon
qu'ils utilisent
est ce que vous savez pourquoi pas du
tout c'est pas du tout parce qu'ils
veulent le garder pour plus tard à cause
du gaz ce qui s'est passé aux états unis
c'est que l'explosion de l'exploitation
de gaz de roche mère celle gaz a divisé
les prix du gaz par trois et du coup a
rendu les centrales à gaz plus
compétitifs que les centrales à charbon
et donc les opérateurs bascule du
charbon au gaz
et pas plus tard qu'il ya quelques jours
il ya une petite information qui est
paru en disant que sous présidence 30 il
y avait cinquante centrales à charbon
qui avait fermé aux états unis il ya
beaucoup plus que sous présidence obama
équivalente ce qui montrait et soit dit
en passant de choses mais on va y
revenir dans les cours suivants c'est
que 1 les déterminants de l'action ne
sont pas nécessairement uniquement dans
le discours présidentiel en fait ils
sont un peu partout sauf dans le
discours présidentiel à court terme en
général c'est la vie c'est comme ça
qu'il faut se méfier de ce qui se passe
à la surface des vagues parce que des
fois il se passe des trucs en dessous
qui sont beaucoup plus déterminants donc
aux états unis
l'élément vraiment déterminant ça a été
l'effondrement du prix du gaz est donc
le basculement du pétrole du charbon
vers le gaz dans la génération
électrique alors une fois que c'est fini
ça voilà ce que mis bout-à-bout dans un
projet qu'on avait mené au shit ya
quelques années on se disait qu'on
pouvait avoir comme approvisionnement
maximal au cours du temps si on ne prend
comme celles contraintes que la géologie
dit autrement maintenant là je me dis je
viens pas au cours d'après et au cours
d' encore après le climat j'm'en fous
comme multiples et man tout ce qui
compte c'est combien je peux m'en sortir
du sous-sol est montée raide de rôle
d'accord le reste je m'en fous et donc
je vais regarder quelle est la limite
haute de mon approvisionnements avec mes
seules contraintes géologiques
alors la réponse vous avez quelque chose
qui ressemble à ça sur le graphique que
je vous montre
dit autrement la magie des exponentielle
vous vous rappelez de cette blague sur
les exponentielle vous a probablement
déjà fait cette blague vous avez une
mare dans laquelle les dés du phare
double de surface tous les jours la
connaissez vous avez une manif ayotte
vous avez une mare dans laquelle à
l'aîné du phare double de surface tous
les jours et il a fallu trente jours
pour que les nénuphars occupe la moitié
de la surface de la barre combien de
temps reste-t-il avant qu'ils occupent
toute la surface
réponse un jour la magie des
exponentielle fait que même si vous
déplacer un peu vers le haut les
ressources extractibles de ces
combustibles fossiles vous ne décalé pas
le pic de 45 ans + 37 supplémentaires
d'accord la magie 2 exponentielle fait
que le pic joue à quelques décennies
tout au plus en fonction des hypothèses
même très très favorable que vous
pourriez prendre sur la quantité totale
de ressources extractibles sur les
réserves ultimes donc ce que je suis en
train de vous dire c'est que d'ici à ce
que vous passiez de vie à trépas
si votre espérance de vie est bien de 80
ans et quelques à la naissance eh bien
il est assez vraisemblable que vous
vivrez quelle qu'en soit la cause
le pic de production mondiale du pétrole
du gaz et vraisemblablement du charbon
et je veux finir pour introduire le
cours de la prochaine fois en dix ans
en plus si on se soucie du climat il est
souhaitable que ça arrive demain matin
dit autrement la contrainte climat si on
veut respecter les fameux de degré dont
vous avez tous entendu parler maintenant
est plus dure que la contrainte
géologiques sur la quantité de
combustible fossile que nous avons le
droit de sortir du sol et d'utiliser il
n'empêche que cette voiture balai existe
quand même et donc il n'existe pas
d'émissions de co2 qui pourrait croître
indéfiniment et donc tout le court que
je vous ai donné aujourd'hui il porte
sur oust et la voiture balai si on se
fiche du climat en gros c'est ça l'idée
est bien à la prochaine fois
c'est vrai
steve dû leur survie
kevin barnes est pas sûr que non je l'aï
dit il ya la même valeur